Alright.
Oh wait,
where are we going live?
Boom.
Mic live.
Mr Carroll.
How are you sir?
I'm very good feedback.
Very good to have you back.
So,
uh,
you have a podcast now?
I do.
I've joined the ranks.
You've inspired me.
Well,
you know,
it's important.
We need people like you out there.
You are,
you have like,
what,
seven episodes so far?
Seven episodes up a few more in the can.
I'm going to try to dribble mail once a
week,
uh,
for the first six months or so.
See how it goes.
Are you enjoying the process?
I am mindscape by the way,
is the name for those out there in
podcast land?
Yeah,
I'm loving it.
You know,
the,
the real,
the thing that tilted me over toward
doing it because like,
look,
it's,
I have a day job,
right?
I can't spend too much time doing this
stuff.
Um,
but what I realized it was an excuse,
a licensed to talk to people who are not
just physicists,
right?
Because like I had the intellectual
interests that go way beyond just what I
do for a living.
And in academia,
you're not allowed to take seriously
anything other than your discipline,
your job,
right?
I'm allowed to be talking about physics,
but nothing else.
But so now I can talk to historians and
economists and philosophers and
psychologists and it's great.
Well,
you could've just gone to evergreen
state and then you could talk about
anything.
Teaching a professor.
You could just,
if you're a professor,
you could teach them dance.
We have to break it out of the system.
We have to do it ourselves.
Yeah,
man.
Got To break out of that system.
So your podcast,
you decided that this would be a great
venue for you to just to expand on
subjects and just get into anything that
you'd like.
Well,
you know,
I,
I have opinions about things and I've
never been one who said you shouldn't
talk about things unless you're a phd.
Credentialed expert,
right?
I think everyone should be talking about
everything,
but you should know what your level of
expertise is.
So if you're not an expert and you
should listen to people and they should
then make your own decisions.
But you should first gathered the
information and so I don't feel quite
like I can go,
I have a blog and write whatever I want
on my blog,
but I can't really expound on my
theories of economics because what do I
know about economics,
but I can call up but very expert
economist and chat with them when the
podcast and both I will learn something
and hopefully the listeners as well.
So you're going to just basically talk
about anything.
The shtick is we sort of tried to pick
an idea,
right?
So for the hour or whatever it is,
I don't have your statement.
I can't do the two and a half hour
thing.
I know I need more.
I need more nitrogen caffeine in me.
But uh,
yeah,
for an hour,
hour and a half,
uh,
I'll get someone who's an expert and
we'll dig into an idea and try to
understand what's going on,
you know,
in,
in sort of everyday people's language
and how it fits into the bigger picture
and things like that.
And uh,
trying to mix up,
you know,
good old professors,
which are my peer group to sort of,
I got some people coming out of left
field.
I had a professional poker player,
I have a movie director coming up,
a chef and things like that.
So,
but basically,
yeah,
whatever I want to talk about.
That's awesome.
So is this for your own edification or
are you just using it as just a
platform?
Like what?
Yeah,
I think that my,
like philosophically I treat it like
it's for me,
right?
Like I'm not going to do guests or
topics or not do topics because the
people say so.
Right,
right.
There's plenty of people out there who
don't want me to talk about anything
other than physics or at least nothing
that involves politics or religion.
Stay in your lane,
Bro.
Very much.
Right.
But I love talking about politics and
religion.
So guess what,
I'm going to talk about those things.
Um,
and so,
and then hopefully it finds an audience,
right.
And uh,
so I'm willing to listen to suggestions,
but mostly I have to treat it like it's
for me.
Well,
I think it's absurd to ask someone to
not talk about things if people love
doing it.
Like I especially love,
you know,
the commenters saying,
Oh,
you know,
of course he's a scientist so he knows
nothing about politics.
I'm like,
you're an anonymous youtube commentor.
Why should I listen to your opinions
about politics?
You definitely can't listen to the
opinions of anybody that's willing to
take the time to comment on Youtube.
What?
That's a problem with that whole bit
about it because I was like,
what kind of a person does that?
Like who,
who listens to a video and goes wall
time that are put her in March.
He takes it very rare breed.
Unless they have like a real specific
expertise in what's being discussed.
Like maybe it's about auto repair and
like that is not how you replace a
transmission.
Here's why.
Or if you just ask him questions like I
love my calendar's like mostly the
comments even on my youtube,
like so I send the video,
I don't do video,
right?
I'm just doing audio podcasts.
But you can put them on youtube with the
static image and for some reason people
like that.
People listen to podcasts on Youtube,
right?
Yeah.
And uh,
the comments have actually overall been
surprisingly good because youtube is one
of the worst,
right?
And overall,
but you know,
people say like,
oh,
I didn't know that or tell me more about
this or this was interesting.
That's great.
By all means do it.
But if you're like,
don't talk about that,
I want to hear about this,
then you know,
block,
go away.
It only takes a tiny drop of Lsd to
pollute a whole bucket of water.
There you can really,
what the deal is with youtube comments,
it's just the sheer number of people
there.
The problem is that youtube has a
dedicated group of shitheads and trolls
for whatever reason.
I don't know why would that platform
seems to track some of the worst in
people that comment and I'm,
you know,
I cannot claim that I'm immune to a
reading it and getting annoyed.
I'm like,
you idiot,
I know.
I should just say forget it.
Move on with my life.
And I'm like,
dammit,
well it's,
it's interesting in a lot of ways.
I mean there's something fascinating
about this new form of communication
where someone can send this a very just
flat text,
you don't know anything about the
background of the person who's sending
it and there's a style of doing that
that's designed to kind of mess with
your head just to poke out your nerves.
Right?
And I look,
let's let,
let me just,
you know,
just to redress the balance here.
Um,
it's great that we have these new ways
of talking to each other.
Right?
And part of glancingly mentioned the
fact that academia wants you to stay in
your lane very,
very much.
And I think that that's a shame.
And so I think that part of the many
hidden purposes of my podcast,
one of them is to dissolve the boundary
between science and the rest of our
intellectual life.
Right?
Like,
I'm not going to.
Sometimes they'll be talking about
science,
sometimes I won't.
Like we,
we tend to silo off science as a thing.
And then like economy,
economics and history and political
science is another thing that is out
there and relevant to the world and
science is something that is sort of a
form of entertainment for a lot of
people and I want to mix it all up by
the different people talking to each
other.
And so overall by all means comment on
the youtube videos and you'll keep that
conversation going.
That's good of you.
That's,
that's,
that's a very healthy attitude and
that's kind of the attitude that you
have to have if you're putting
everything out there.
Yeah.
And just one more irony is like,
I'm not a,
I don't seek conflict.
I'm a conflict averse person.
Like I just want,
I don't want to argue with people,
but I do want to say things that are
true and not everyone agrees about what
is true.
So there's going to be arguments.
So I put up with that,
but I'm not seeking it out.
So I would like this utopia of rational
discourse where everyone is talking
about ideas in a dispassionate way and
in good faith looking toward moving
toward the truth.
It would be nice if we had like a
system,
like almost like a rating system for
humans,
like a yelp for commentators that people
are trying,
that it's not a bad idea.
It really isn't.
In terms of like,
like people review your comments on
things and enough people decide like
this is just unnecessary yelp for
expertise or for commentary and
generally all the above.
Yeah,
I mean I think uh,
we're probably going to move to some
sort of a system like that.
In fact,
some people are actually advocating that
for society to have some sort of a like
a rating system for people and almost a
new kind of currency,
like a social currency.
They're doing it in China.
Right?
You've heard this scary for people
though because it's China and China is
a,
it's a trippy place and it's very trippy
in terms of.
It's sort of got capitalism going,
but it's also a communist dictatorship
and this is big for the government in
the.
All the companies are also in,
you know,
the thing with Huawei.
Am I saying it right?
People are getting mad at me about that.
Huawei,
I think it's Walway,
it's the now that number two cell phone
manufacturer in the world and they're
for bidden to work with us carriers.
The United States does not trust this
company.
So they've said,
you know,
this company is apparently done some
shading things according to them,
not according to certain tech people say
it's nonsense,
but there so that another,
keeping them from selling their cell
phones with 18 t and t mobile,
whatever.
Uh,
but they're the number two manufacturer
in the world now that just surpassed
apple because China is just.
Okay.
Yeah,
China's a trip.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's,
they know very well.
It's kind of remarkable to me that China
has been so stable and successful
because there are,
you know,
people who don't like it.
There are people who rebel against the
system,
but they've been.
So the government's been so enormously
successful in controlling inflammation.
Yeah,
totally.
What you learn,
like you can't Google Tiananmen Square
if you're trying to a,
you can't get those images or anything
like that.
And companies want to do business there
so they'll go along with it.
And I'm not sure if it's stable
building.
Anyhow,
I talked about this when I last podcast
with the ultra monk.
I'm not sure that democracy is stable
either,
so,
um,
when,
when the technological capabilities are
changing so rapidly,
a huge abuses and huge changes are on
the horizon.
Even we don't know what they're going to
be.
I mean,
that's,
that's my worry about the social credit
system,
right?
Like,
it's.
So obviously abusable make the wrong
people have bad credit and make the
people you like.
I mean,
if this is run by the government,
you're going to trust them to,
uh,
do it fairly.
I,
you know,
I'm a little skeptical about that.
Well,
I think this last election and the
subsequent analysis of the manipulation
of the election has been very eyeopening
to people.
And,
um,
the,
the Russian troll farms,
have you been paying attention to that
stuff?
That is,
that is a stunning revelation that
there's 24 slash seven businesses where
people are set up where they're hired to
just tweet and post things and comment
on things.
And they're all working in some way to
try to manipulate the way people look at
the news.
Yeah,
and the most interesting thing to me,
I thought like if they were clever,
they will do this and they do it.
It's not just that they have a policy
that they want to push,
right?
Or candidate they want to push,
they want to foment disagreement.
They will take the most radical views on
either side and pump them up just so
Americans are tearing at each other's
throats.
And yeah,
that kind of works.
Right?
That's,
that's pretty successful so far.
There was a radiolab podcast where these
people that were trump supporters
detailed being contacted by these
Russian troll farms where they organize
these rallies and they organize these
protests and they even hired a fake
hillary.
They fought,
they hired a fake trump and they're
gonna have the Hillary and a cage and
they wanted everybody to yell out,
lock her up and this,
these Russians coordinated this whole
thing.
Right.
And then once it starts,
know,
organically
takes over.
Right?
I mean,
you,
you probably saw just the other day this
a trump rally where the CNN reporter was
trying to do a seminar.
I'm trying to do a camera spot and he
just like got drowned out by people
shouting at him and you know,
shouting obscenities and I,
I don't know what,
that,
that's bad.
Right?
Okay.
I mean,
it's bad.
The media.
I wouldn't want that to happen to Fox
News.
I wouldn't want that to happen to people
that disagree with you.
GotTa let the people in the media,
but media,
they're not the enemy of the people and
what he's done is very dangerous.
You know,
it's,
it's very,
it's very sneaky and very dangerous and
it's very manipulative and he's
essentially,
he's in survival mode and when people
are in survival mode,
they,
he's not thinking at all about the
importance of the press.
He's thinking about his,
his situation,
his stance,
his position in life.
Preserve that.
And what's the best way to preserve that
when someone's attacking me,
attack the people who are attacking me.
Any.
Yeah.
You build yourself up by creating an
enemy that everyone can agree on right?
One of the chilling things that you
pointed out,
there's really,
despite the rhetoric,
there's never been a successful,
truly multiethnic democracy in the
history of the world,
like democracies that have worked,
have worked because one group is the
boss,
right?
And you know,
they give rights to the rest of the
people and so forth and try to be fair
to some extent,
but that's changing,
like as the demographics of the world
are changing,
uh,
we're,
we're becoming more of the patchwork
that we claimed to be years ago and
people aren't quite happy with that.
They're not comfortable with it.
And this is something that can be used
to gin up emotional reactions.
Yeah.
There's people are terrified of change
too.
So is this nostalgia for the past?
Yeah.
And you know,
the past that is not necessarily
accurate that they,
that they,
that they envision.
Um,
and,
and it's,
and I'm sympathetic with the real
problems,
right?
They're real problems with inequality
and with healthcare and with jobs and
you know,
not just the number of jobs,
but the jobs are changing.
Not everyone is really tooled up to be a
high tech,
a office worker in this day and age and
so I take those concerns really,
really seriously,
but those concerns being channeled and
very unproductive ways to scapegoat
people who don't deserve it.
One of the things,
it's fascinating to me,
this seems to be boiling under the
surface is the possibility that we might
need some sort of universal basic income
to deal with what's happening with ai
and automate automate station like auto
automation of m cars,
automation of normal jobs that put food
preparation and things that people have
come to.
Just take for granted that a human's
going to be doing that.
It's entirely possible that millions and
millions and millions of people are
going to be out of work within a very
short period of time and it seems to me
that it's just.
It's one of those sneaky things that
might just catch us before we're ready
for it.
Yeah.
I think that if you extrapolate very far
ahead into the future and imagining what
utopia is supposed to look like or you
know the far technologically advanced
civilization,
why wouldn't we imagined that work is
done by robots and machines and human
beings are free to be creative or
artistic or athletic or just sit on
their butts if that's what they want to
do.
If you believe that that's a possible
future than the way to get there is to,
as robots and machines do more and more,
make it more and more possible for
people to live without working.
I think that's a is at least I have no
idea whether it works in practice.
I'm not an economist.
I haven't studied it,
but I think it should be taken seriously
as an idea.
If you looked at it as a pessimist and
if you looked at it with a cynical
perspective,
you'd say,
well,
people just want.
They don't have motivation.
Then they behave like rich kids or
entitled people or people who won the
lottery.
They blow all the money.
They don't take it seriously because
they didn't earn it.
It goes against human nature.
Yep.
I get that.
And maybe it does let them do it.
Who,
who am I to tell people that they need
to be virtuous by earning a living in
some job they may or may not be able to
keep for very long.
The people who say that usually haven't
gotten fired from their jobs raise.
Right?
Right,
right.
Yeah.
And I always feel like the people that
are actually ambitious but the real
problem,
and I think we'd be growing up with
that,
I think if you,
you've got it as an adult,
you'd probably recognize it as a safety
net.
It is.
But as if it was during your
developmental process,
you might rely on it as a constant.
Yeah.
And so that might be a problem in terms
of motivation.
I think so,
and I think that,
uh,
and you see it,
right?
I mean,
I,
I have friends at various levels of
income and class that they grew up in
and you can always tell people who grew
up in very comfortable,
uh,
environments because they don't have
jobs,
they have projects.
I'm working on a project because they're
not really worried about the project
failing.
You know,
like if you grew up without that safety
net,
you're more cautious.
Like you have to have a fail safe,
you have to have a backup plan and.
But what if everyone had that backup
plan?
What if we could all do projects instead
of work?
Is that really a worse world?
I didn't know any trust fund people.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The ones that I know all blow their
money.
Actually I know some,
I know some very wealthy people who
raise their kids really well and you
trust fund people.
Oh yeah.
As people who like never need to work a
day in their lives and they all work
really hard.
That's so weird.
It's possible.
Find those people and clone them.
Yeah.
Find out what made them tick,
what was there.
So they found a passion.
They found something that they're
actually,
that seems to be a giant issue.
That's right.
And your parents need to sort of
encouraged that,
you know,
um,
parents matter when it comes to like,
if you're,
if you are very wealthy,
do you feel like you deserve it or do
you feel like,
oh,
I should give something back because I'm
really,
really fortunate.
Well,
there's cockamamie ideas that come from
people that haven't earned their money
to,
like one guy came to him with this crazy
idea for this project he's doing and
wanting me to get involved in it.
And I was,
I was going over the details of it.
I was like,
I don't think this is going to work.
Like why?
Why is this guy so enthusiastic about
it?
And then the more I dug into it,
I'm like,
oh,
he got all this money from his dad.
Oh,
well you go,
this guy is just,
he just,
he's got pipe dreams.
Yeah,
I mean,
I guess I feel just to be honest about
it,
like I'm very lucky,
uh,
not because I grew up wealthy because I
didn't.
But because I now have a job that
represents what I want to do,
like what I would do with my life if I
were independently wealthy.
Isn't that different from what I'm doing
right now?
Right.
That's exactly.
But therefore I kind of think that I
would like a world where everyone can do
that.
If that's what they wanted,
that would be amazing.
Yeah.
The real question is,
does everybody have an actual interest?
And if they don't,
is it nurture or nature?
do we force them to.
Is that we want to do something you
love,
find something you love.
The thing I,
you know,
I'm actually,
I never tell people like,
follow your passion or plain what do you
love?
Because look,
there's a lot of people who need to earn
a living,
right?
He's loving people who just need to do
work because they need to pay the bills.
That's fine.
That should be respected.
That in the we have right now,
that's an an honorable thing to do and
not everyone gets to just do what they
love.
That's true.
There are some things though that you
can do for a living.
They you'll actually enjoy,
like you need to make a living,
but because of your temperament,
because your interests,
you can find a thing,
whether it's carpentry or whatever it is
that you find to be fascinating and
fulfilling when you're actually doing.
You're making a living,
but you're also doing something that,
man,
I.
This is very satisfying.
Maybe,
maybe that's true.
I mean,
it's certainly true.
It can be done.
Can it be done for everyone in the
world?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
Well,
there's so many styles of living too.
You know,
when you're talking about China.
Uh,
I was in China recently.
We spent some time in Thailand and we
flew through China.
And one of the things you realized about
China is that just a totally different
way of moving.
Like people just walk right through
people.
Yeah.
I mean they,
their lines,
if there's a space and align the peanut,
they don't respect that space.
They go right into that space right in
front of you.
Like,
oh,
there's a space there.
They didn't even think of it as rude.
It's not just the style,
right?
Yeah.
It's just this week we went through
Southeast Asia for a few weeks and you
know,
visited Vietnam and Thailand and they're
right next to each other,
but just the behavior and the city's
utterly different.
Like just walking down the street.
It's just a different culture.
I haven't been to Vietnam.
What was that like?
Vietnam was my favorite.
It was,
yeah.
Everybody says that.
It's great.
I mean,
I don't know.
I was there for a few days.
Right.
I'm sure that there's depths to the
country that I didn't perceive.
But uh,
you know,
it was coming to life literally the week
we were,
there was the first.
Mcdonald's was opening in Vietnam,
so,
which is not good,
but at least it meant it was.
We were there in a pre Mcdonald's
society.
Right.
And the,
it was physically very beautiful.
The food was amazing.
It was all scattered,
shot,
like the people just go crazy on the
streets in any direction they want and
it was not organized or anything like
that,
but it was very genuine,
you know,
it was.
People were trying to be nice,
people seem to be very friendly like
that.
We didn't speak any other language or
anything like that.
And uh,
it was just a wonderful experience
overall.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
A Asia is a trip.
It's a really different part of the
world.
China is,
yeah.
I've been trying to,
to,
and it's,
it's a,
that's a trip for a different reason.
Right.
And uh,
you know,
I,
it,
I'm scared by China in the sense that I,
I'm worried that they will succeed while
still being repressive dictatorship.
Right.
Like,
uh,
I remember reading these memoirs from
Bertrand Russell when he visited China
and uh,
he was rhapsodizing about this is an
amazing culture,
amazing people.
This is great.
And I'm like,
does he not know it's a communist
dictatorship?
And then my brain kicked in.
I'm like,
oh no,
it was 1912.
It was not a communist dictatorship at
the time.
And that there's a great tragedy in the
way that China has been sort of
repressed for so long.
I think there's immense potential and
promise there,
but it's also the possibility that they
just remain in this autocracy forever
and some people's lives improve and a
lot of people just drudgery for billions
of people.
Yeah.
It's totally possible.
It's,
it's fascinating that they become this
combination of things.
Yeah.
A combination of both capitalism and
communism.
Yeah.
Well I think that's it.
Like they found a release valve,
like he couldn't,
you couldn't be.
The Soviet Union was going to collapse
because it was,
it's a terrible system,
right.
Then,
you know,
economically,
politically,
whatever.
And China found this little bit of
balance where they still have the
repressive dictatorship,
but they give enough freedom for people
to be ambitious and try to get ahead and
that improves the economy and they make
some terrible mistakes.
Right.
They're these huge cities that are
built.
No one lives there.
And there's these spooky pictures.
Right.
So you've seen the recreations of other
large cities like Paris.
I've seen that.
And sometimes like cities like Shenzhen,
like right next to Hong Kong,
it's a city of 5 million people.
Thirty years ago it was 50,000 people,
right?
Like it just,
they built it in a couple of years and,
and other places like,
oh,
we'll build a shopping mall here where
there's nothing.
It's just instantly,
it's,
it looks like Detroit the next day.
There's no one there knew.
No one makes a,
no one builds anything.
No one does anything with it because
it's not really capitalism.
It's still a planned economy.
And there's pluses and minuses with
that.
No doubt.
One of the big fears about China is
there experimentation with genetics is
a,
they're willing to do things ethically
that scientists in America and a lot of
parts of the western world are not
willing to engage in yet.
Yeah.
Including the use of Crispr on human
embryos.
Yep.
And I think,
uh,
so I have mixed feelings about that.
I think it's going to happen in our
culture.
I think we're going to do it right.
I actually had.
I'm sorry I haven't released that
podcast yet,
but stay tuned.
I have an excellent podcast coming with
Carl Zimmer,
who was a science writer,
just wrote a long book about heredity
and genetics and uh,
yeah,
so what they're going to be doing a with
the designer
babies.
It's not science fiction as far as I can
tell it's going to happen and uh,
but it's very unclear what it will mean
because we're not any good right now.
And figuring out how genetics turns,
how your DNA turns into a person,
right?
Yeah.
It might be like,
you know,
that we find something other that if you
increase,
if you change this particular gene,
uh,
sure you can live twice as long,
but also you'll have Parkinson's disease
when you're fortunate,
right?
Like we don't know what the
interdependencies are and stuff like
that.
Uh,
so,
but,
but it's coming.
I think that the idea that we will be
choosing embryos to come to term and be
people on the basis of their jeans
before they're,
you know,
a implanted in the uterus is,
is 100 percent that's going to happen.
And the chance that we're gonna be
editing them is 99 point nine,
nine percent chance.
And you're right,
China is way more willing to do that.
And again,
I'm not really sure if that's good or
bad,
you know,
I think it's going to come here.
What I'm more worried about is that,
you know,
people figure out a system that will
make a,
you can have a baby who's guaranteed to
be,
you know,
tall and beautiful and smart and live
for a hundred 50 years and it'll cost
you a million dollars,
then that'll be a little bit unfair.
Right.
That'll be an issue that will come up.
Yeah.
But then isn't it unfair that the rock
is the rock?
How did he get to be the rock?
It is,
but I think just psychologically it's a.
I think he worked hard,
but he also had his giant started.
Yeah,
he started in the right place.
You know the story of Almay,
right?
No.
Good.
So yeah,
being the basketball player from China,
he was basically the result of a
breeding program really.
Like they encouraged his parents who
were both really tall basketball players
to have a baby and you know,
it worked for him.
It doesn't always work because it's a
crap shoot.
But uh,
um,
it can work.
Yeah.
And so,
but that's normal breeding.
That's like a dog.
And my dog's a good looking dog.
Her dog at the same breed,
let's put them together.
That's right.
With human beings.
But yes.
Otherwise normal.
Yes.
And it,
it,
I think it's different.
It's different psychologically because
we think it's different winning the
lottery than already being rich and
therefore being able to afford something
that changes who you are.
Right.
I think that,
I don't know,
maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe people will think that that's
awesome.
And will these people will be
celebrities and we'll follow them on
instagram,
but I suspect people be rubbed the wrong
way at that kind of access to something
that most people can't afford it most
certainly will.
The most certainly.
Well,
but I think if you look at it
objectively,
if you look at the interactions of the
species,
as you know,
a completely a outside observer,
you would say not only is this
inevitable,
but this is going to lead to some really
spectacular changes in what a human
being is like.
Think about a big part of what we're
concerned with constantly on a daily
basis is healthcare,
right?
People were very concerned
with people that have to deal with
debilitating diseases and if we could
just eliminate all those.
Yeah.
Why wouldn't you want that?
I think you probably will be able to,
and it will probably happen.
That I think is.
Yeah,
but then so far almost everyone agrees
with that.
Like it's not the controversial part,
right?
Like yeah,
if we can eliminate,
and apparently some diseases we already
know like right there in your DNA,
you're going to get Huntington's when
you're 40 years old.
Right?
And so those are easy to eliminate
peanut allergies or something like that
to other diseases are harder.
We don't know what causes them,
so it'll take time,
but I think that there'll be
uncontroversial if you could just remove
diseases from people ahead of time.
It's a little bit different if you're
choosing their hair color and skin color
and shape of their nose and feed and
whatever.
That gets a little squirrelly,
but it's also when the idea of it being
a cost prohibitive issue.
Well isn't that the case with almost all
technology as it emerges?
It's very memorable.
Plasma Tvs,
we're like $20,000 for a small
television.
I remember I saw them.
It was only like a 30 inch television or
something like that was exorbitant and I
was like,
this is incredible.
Flat hangs on the wall now.
Everybody has them and they're cheap.
You can get one for a few hundred bucks
and it's way bigger and way better than
what it was back then.
Yeah,
and I think they actually,
that's very realistic.
That maybe will be million dollars,
but then 10 years later we'll be
$100,000 to sort of be a million dollars
first.
Right.
It kind of just like cell phones,
like everything else,
it has to be a really expensive thing
and then eventually trickles down like
cell phones and becomes available
everywhere to everybody.
Like if you look at the average person's
cell phone,
if you buy the cheap cell phone for like
300 bucks,
it is way better than an iphone from 10
years ago.
Yeah.
In every way.
No,
I think that's probably right.
And I think that it's one of the things
that's happening,
like we're,
we're still at the beginning of
technology,
right?
Technology's not that advanced compared
to where it's going to be.
Um,
you know,
I have another podcast guests coming up
who is an expert on aging and how we can
fix that by messing with jeans a little
bit gray.
No,
no.
This was a real scientist at Princeton.
You know,
someone who's just doing experimental
scientists.
Uh,
well he's,
I don't know him that well,
so I shouldn't say,
but I,
I think of it as an advocate for anti
aging,
which is good,
which is cool.
But,
but my guest,
Colleen Murphy,
he's just like a biologist who was
working on things and discovered
something that was,
she's not trying that hard,
right?
Uh,
you knock out a certain gene in this
certain worm and it lived twice as long
and without any twoK ,
right?
Like,
it doesn't get old because it's
fascinating.
Like why do we die?
Why do we grow old?
It's not necessary.
Like you could design an organism that
doesn't get older.
It would die from random bad things.
You get hit on the head with a brick,
but you don't need to die.
The reality is that evolution programmed
aging and death into us because once we
have kids or once we've outlived our
reproductive lifespan,
we're not useful anymore.
So biology is once us to die.
And so that,
that,
in other words,
it's potentially fixable.
You know,
it might not be easy,
it might be not happened 100 years from
now,
but it could.
So I think that,
you know,
aging,
genetic engineering,
brain,
computer interfaces,
you know,
all that stuff is going to within the
next hundred years totally changed what
it means to be human being and we're
totally not ready for it.
And so I was saying this to Carl
[inaudible] Carl's like,
not that Carl Zimmer was more or less
sanguine about is like don't worry,
just,
you know,
we'll put regulations on,
it'll be fine.
And my attitude was,
no,
actually we should think of the absolute
craziest science fiction scenarios
because I want to be prepared,
right.
You know,
it doesn't come to pass.
I want to worry about the least probable
things because it might spark something
that actually helps us down the road.
Yeah.
There was a recent discovery.
They figured out a way to shut off
whatever it is that causes wrinkles and
reverse the process.
So whatever is causing your skin to get
wrinkly and sag,
they're reversing that process.
We might be members of the last
generation to die
of old age.
We won't be a mortal.
Well then if you thought you were
immortal,
if you thought,
well,
let's say that you thought that your
average lifespan was a million years,
would you suddenly become way more
cautious?
Oh,
start jumping off buildings and shit
would do.
Like I have a friend of mine who does
the flying squirrel suit stuff.
He holds the world.
You don't become vulnerable.
You just don't.
Exactly.
Flying Squirrels type is truly
dangerous.
Oh,
it's super dangerous.
Yeah.
Base jump.
What if they could just fix you if you
like even,
but that's a separate thing.
Yes,
that's possible.
Right?
Like maybe they get back to your go
back,
you up,
you just die,
but they build to your clone,
put you back together.
Like all these crazy science fiction
series.
I don't think that that's.
I think the backing up is way harder
than people think,
but I think that stopping aging is way
easier than people think.
But we'll see.
I agree with you.
Uh,
I went to the 20,
45,
I think they're calling it a conference
in New York City a few years back ago.
It's all the ray Kurzweil advocates that
think you're going to download brains
into computers and stuff.
Not that compelling like that,
that stuff.
I was like,
what are you going to do with what's
going to happen?
It seems like everybody had this idea of
one day we'll be able to do this and
we'll be able to take consciousness,
and I'm like,
yeah,
it's not.
I mean a,
b doesn't violate the laws of physics,
but it's hopelessly impractical compared
to anything we can do right now.
Like the human brain is just not
something you can read out.
My question,
and this was something that really
concerned me was what's to keep someone
from making hundreds of thousands of
versions of themselves?
Like what if,
what to take someone from some,
you know,
really rich billionaire character that
can afford to do this and say,
I'm going to do this many,
many times.
Then I'm going to have my clones make
clones of clones and I'm going to fill
up a whole island with me.
Why would you do that though?
Because you're a crazy person.
Okay.
I mean,
crazy.
People are allowed to do crazy things,
but imagine if you had 100 Sean
Carroll's near House working on things
but it,
but they're not the same person.
What if you found that the 30,
the Sean Carroll Smoking crack and
hookers drawing fast direction.
Imagine.
Have you realized that that like after a
while there,
there is a random.
Sure,
yeah.
Is Evo Devo,
right?
Did you grow up in matters?
That would be really fascinating if that
would be an excellent episode of black
mirror where someone clone themselves
and found out that a certain percentage
of the clowns were just fucking crazy or
they were the crazy one.
Right?
Like all the clones were very different
than them and they rolled seem to each
other or maybe having all those clones
somehow or another set something off in
them that made them crazy because they
were in competition with all these other
people that were exactly like them.
This is golden.
Yeah.
We should edit this out of the podcast
so we can write up this episode.
There's a real concern with messing with
biology in a way that's never been done
before.
Exactly,
and I think that the extent to which
it's coming is something we haven't
quite faced up to you and it's really
coming.
It's coming fast and profoundly and
we're not ready.
Yeah.
And the possibility of just creating a
world that we're not prepared for and
we're not prepared for the consequences
of.
Yeah,
exactly.
All in favor of thinking crazy.
Right?
Like just wondering what it will be like
even if the answer is no,
that'll never happen.
At least,
you know,
be prepared a little bit.
Uh,
you know,
think of all the alarms.
Crazy scenarios.
Yeah.
Um,
have you really gotten into crispr?
Have you really looked into that stuff
at all?
Not that much,
you know,
a little too applied to real world for
my taste,
but people don't know what we're talking
about.
We're talking,
it's a new technique for editing genes
that was discovered accidentally while
examining the effects of the story is
it's
amazing.
I mean there are these bacteria,
you know,
so we,
here's the thing,
we think of DNA as where our genetic
information is stored,
right?
Like you have a little code,
it's a little list of symbols,
a cgt and their inner hero and that's
it.
That is handed down from parents to
children,
but the reality is way more complicated
than that because different parts of the
DNA do things and different ones don't.
Some of them get turned on,
turned off.
We have mitochondrial DNA which are not
our DNA.
We had these little sub cells within us
that get carried along for the ride and
have their own DNA and so crispr is this
thing that was invented by nature,
right?
Not by human beings.
These bacteria who were trying to resist
viruses.
Right?
So the viruses would come in and attack
them and basically the de,
the bacteria learned away to steel part
of the DNA of the virus and keep it as
like a facial recognition software.
It's like a template.
Like,
Oh,
this DNA thing is approaching me that's
a virus and I should attack it.
Right?
Like this is something that I knew.
I learned how to fight off.
And so to do that need to be able to
snip out a little piece of DNA.
And so scientists,
biologists learned that they could
train,
this is a little bit fanciful way,
putting it metaphorical,
but they could train the bacteria to go
in there,
snip out pieces of DNA,
and you can do that for any dna you
want.
So,
but,
and you can replace it with something
else.
Uh,
it's not really very high precision
right now,
but that's coming.
And so in principle,
this is,
you know,
a little way to change the genetic code
and then they figured out some other way
that ordinarily,
right,
if you have two parents and you have
like Brown eyes versus blue eyes and
blue eyes are recessive.
So they both need to have the blue eye
gene to give you if you want to have
blue eyes.
But they figured out a way that you can
change the DNA and it automatically with
100 percent accuracy gets sent to all of
your offspring,
right?
It's not 50 slash 50 chance or whatever.
Uh,
so then you can just say,
propagate a change in the genetic code
throughout the species pretty darn
quickly.
And your human beings take a long time
to breed.
But animals and plants,
it's a whole nother world,
right?
You can design those very,
very rapidly and there's already been at
least one revision of the process,
right?
I think so,
but yeah.
The.
I think I just told you everything I
know
continuing to improve on the process and
it's really,
it's really gonna be very interesting to
see where that goes as far as that
advances.
Yeah.
I think this was a concern with places
like China,
right?
They're already doing this.
They're already manipulating genetics
and trying to create super people
and I think that the chances that gives
them a great basketball team or greater
than the chances that it gave them a
bunch of brilliant phd scientist.
Well that's where it starts,
right in.
A lot of it starts in competitive
athletics.
Have you paid attention?
Did you watch the documentary?
ICARUS?
No,
I did not.
Fascinating documentary that's on
Netflix right now about it's.
It really is kind of a crazy set of
circumstances.
There's a guy named Bryan Fogel,
he's the director of the producer of the
movie and he was competitive bike racer
and he decided to document what he
wanted to do was compete in a race,
a bike race,
a hundred percent clean,
and then get a Russian scientist to
juice them up.
So in the process of getting this
Russian scientists to juice them up,
he stumbled upon a scandal and in the
middle of him making that,
but it means in a crazy way because this
Russian guy is the head of the Anti
Doping Agency in Russia and it was just
sort of informing him how you would do
this.
So he teaches him and forms of how you
can do this.
While this is all going on.
It turns out that the Russians had
completely cheated their way through the
Sochi Olympics now and it was all
documented and so they were getting
busted.
As this is all going on and he films
this Russian who's the head of it,
escaping Russia,
barely coming to the United States and
being chased and testifying all the
different strategies that the Russians
used in order to completely cheat on,
like at least one entire Olympic team,
like every single athlete was on drugs
and they had a record number of gold
medals and so then he starts detailing
the process and how they did it and they
use forensic test,
examined the urine bottles and showed
that they've been opened even though
they were supposedly not openable and
really,
really interesting stuff,
but that national pride,
the thing about a national pride and you
know,
the,
the ability to win a bunch of gold
medals and athletic dominance is so
important for the morale of,
of these countries that want to
establish superiority,
right?
Yeah.
And there are some people who say,
well,
let's just go for it.
Let's have the old dope Olympics.
Right?
Like people enhance themselves as much
as they possibly can.
And there's an ongoing debate about what
about people who use prosthetics,
right?
Is that fair?
If you lost a leg and you have a
prosthetic leg,
because could that potentially give you
an advantage in a running event or
something like that?
If it were a sufficiently good
prosthetic eye?
I don't know the answer to any of these
questions.
I think it's a little bit weird because
we set up these arbitrary categories for
what is it,
a sporting event and we invented them,
right?
They're not out there in the world and
now we're faced with wholly different
circumstances to what to do about it,
but yeah,
I think that,
you know,
there's.
There's the question of what we should
do,
which is hard.
There's the question of what's going to
happen,
which is it's all going to happen.
All of these things are gonna happen.
I was talking to a guy this past weekend
who's a navy seal and his friend lost
his hand and they gave him a new hand
and they're working on this new handout
that's going to allow him to play piano.
So it's a completely artificial carbon
fiber hand with all these different
things that attach directly to your
nerves and somehow or another he can
control it with
his arm that's going to allow him to
play piano and you're going to tell me
that he could never play the piano
before.
Right now he knows it's in the.
It's in the thing.
It's.
Yeah.
Well this is what I was saying about the
brain computer interfaces.
I think that's the real.
That's even bigger frontier than
synthetic biology or genetic engineering
because computers are really useful for
things.
Robots are very useful for things.
Human beings are just going to sort of
blend in.
It's not like we're gonna have ai and
super healthy humans.
It's,
we're gonna just have everywhere on that
spectrum.
Yeah,
that's what I'm thinking as well.
There's going to be some sort of a
symbiotic thing like a chip or you know,
they tried it with the Google glasses.
Could try to get people to wear that.
But they were goofy.
Yeah.
I put them on.
They felt too science fictiony.
Just like the first portable phones were
these giant things.
Right?
That doesn't matter.
Right.
That's not a longterm prognostication
tool.
Yeah.
Lots of,
uh,
lots of people are working on it.
Elan Musk has a little company that no
one knows,
uh,
that
as they do now.
Yeah.
Well,
people know about it if they care,
but it's not like one of his famous
ones,
right.
Um,
to,
to implant a neural lace or something in
your body that reads your brain neuro
lace.
I don't like the way that sounds.
Whereas if you want a more macho,
wanted the back of your head to open up
your schedule.
But I didn't think of it as I was
thinking of it as like a mesh.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's.
It just seems creepy that it's going to
latch onto your nerves and improve you.
Yeah.
Neuro lace.
You won't need your phone anymore.
Wow.
And where's you went to the back of your
head?
Everyone goes to the back of their head
will always go.
Well,
I
mean,
like the Matrix.
Everybody goes to the back of their
head.
Yeah.
I mean,
right now,
uh,
companies that want to make money in the
short term are building these
nonsurgical,
noninvasive things we like were
something on the front of your head or
wear a cap or something like that,
which can detect frequencies,
vibrations in your brain and you can,
it's very primitive,
but you can move things around,
you can control drones with your brain
without touching anything.
Uh,
but yeah,
the,
if it ever becomes practical,
which is very far from certain,
but the thing to imagine in the far
outside fiction scenario is cracking
open your skull and inserting some
electrodes in their,
closing it back up.
And now you're part of the Super
Internet without doing anything more
than closing your eyes.
Yeah.
And there's also the possibility of
enhancing various,
uh,
thought processes to with transdermal
stimulation.
Like if they could figure out,
you know,
they're doing that now they're,
they've performed a series of tests
where they have people do like certain
tasks and then they put electrodes in a
certain areas of the brain and put an
electric charge.
And that electric charge stimulates
various aspects of the brain and it
allows them to complete certain tasks
quicker and more efficiently.
You know,
I think,
and this is just a kind of uninformed a
belief,
but I suspect that the human brain is
pretty optimized for what it tries to
do.
I think that rather than improving the
brainers,
stimulating it the way forward is to
augment it,
like hook it up to calculators and
Internet and whatever.
You know,
one thing that I don't see talked about
very much but I think will be a real
game changer.
You know,
we talked about phones as if we're
carrying around phones,
but we don't mostly use our phones to
talk to people on the phone.
Right?
We check the email,
check the internet and we take pictures
once you really have.
And again it might not be possible,
but if you really had a direct
connection between your brain and the
Internet,
your eyeballs are a video camera.
Everything you see,
you can record and store somewhere,
right?
So.
And you can lend them to other people or
people can subpoena them or whatever.
Like there's literally no place in the
world that,
that human eyeballs are looking at that
would not be subject to later
inspection.
That is weird and scary and bad.
Right?
It is words carrying bad.
And what if someone comes up with a
better eyeball?
Oh yeah.
Scoop out your old doll eyes and put in
some new awesome ones that you can
record with.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I don't think that a nest.
I think,
I think I absolutely agree that
enhancing it with electronics is
probably the way to go and that having
some sort of,
some sort of symbiotic relationship with
electronics.
But I also think that this transdermal
stimulation can enhance that process on
top of it.
I think there's going to be a bunch of
different things going on at once.
You won't even think about crispr being
something where someone eventually
figures out a way to design various
aspects of the human brain that are more
open to interface with technology,
changing various receptors,
make them more efficient for data to go
straight to the dome.
Yeah.
And I think that,
uh,
there is a short term versus long term
question here,
right?
Like even if what I said is a longterm
truth on the short term,
improving our thinking skills in direct
ways with stimulation or whatever sounds
pretty good.
But maybe you can just do that through
Beta blockers.
There are some drugs or something like
that.
Like I think that that's another thing,
very plausible that will have safe
superefficient drugs.
Someone can take it over the next six
hours,
their way.
Clear thinkers than they were before.
Is there any concern with what's the end
game like what's all this stuff?
I hope so.
I mean,
if you're a super far advanced,
the end game is you realize that life is
not that interesting.
Yeah.
You're like,
well why am I here?
What am I doing with all this little
challenge is helpful actually.
Well in particular if you develop a
mortality,
yeah.
If there's no concern about getting
injured or killed.
Yeah.
I think that people who envision super
far ahead science fiction scenarios and
especially people who envision uploading
brains and consciousness underestimate
the importance of our bodies to who we
are as human beings,
right?
Not just that we're in a body,
but like hunger,
thirst,
exhaustion,
being horny,
like these are motivating factors that
really affect who we are and what we say
and what we do and if you remove all
that,
if you're just a thinking processor in a
computer,
what's your motivation?
Why are you going on?
Right?
Like what are you doing anything at all?
Like I don't think it'll be.
I don't think it will be anything like
the personality,
the person who you are.
If your body is taken away.
That's the big question about artificial
life,
right?
Our or artificial intelligence rather
like what we have very specific needs
that are addressed by our ambitions,
right?
Biological need,
the idea of transferring your genes,
keeping your,
your bloodline,
going,
all that stuff.
There's all these survival instincts
that we have that you necessarily
wouldn't necessarily have if you are an
artificial life form.
Like why would you care if someone
pulled the plug on you?
Why would you try to
survive?
What do you.
What's your purpose here?
Right.
Exact same sort of futile.
If you're.
There's a lot of talk in the Ai,
a existential risk community,
like worrying about artificial
intelligence,
about value alignment,
like making sure that the ais value the
same things that we do.
Like our existence for example,
right?
Yeah,
and,
but I think a little bit,
at least what I hear,
and I'm not an expert,
but I hear it seems a little bit off the
mark because they're talking about what
to program into the AI,
but if it's in any sense really an ai,
it can reprogram itself,
right?
You can change your mind as a human
being.
You can change your values.
You can change your motivations.
Artificial intelligence is should be
able to do the same thing and in fact
they better be able to do that if
they're going to be truly intelligent.
If they're.
If we're going to mimic what a human
being can do,
a,
it can't be something where we
programmed them,
just do a task because that's not
intelligent.
Right?
So if that happens there,
then you know who knows what they're
going to eventually be motivated to do.
If anything,
like you said,
like what is their motivation even to do
anything at all or even to exist?
Well isn't.
One of the big concerns is that in
releasing artificial technology and
giving it autonomy that we're going to
do is like start a process that some
sort of a perpetual exponential domino
effect of technology where this new
artificial life is going to create
better artificial life which creates
better artificial life,
which expands to godlike powers within a
very short period of time and decides
where he's stupid and useless and just
eliminates us and then it gets bored and
shuts itself off.
Yeah.
He goes,
what are we doing here?
The Sun's going to burn out and these
are hard
things to even extrapolate because
they're so far beyond our experience,
but I do think that we're opening up
doors that we never had before.
Between between a genetic modifications
of human beings,
artificial intelligence,
brain computer interfaces,
uh,
we,
we don't have the experience or the
capacity to really even ask the right
questions about these things.
Right?
We're sort of rudimentary.
Early were rudimentary idea.
The idea is that we have of like what is
necessary or really based on our own
biological needs.
We have family.
We want to keep everybody healthy,
we enjoy our community,
we want to keep it safe.
We enjoy our,
our earth who want to keep it clean.
We want to,
we want to save things for the future
generations and all these concerns that
we have that are very biological,
they just won't exist for artificial
life.
That's exactly right.
And I think that what we're really good
at or what we're better at in terms of
imagining the future is taking what
already exists and just expanding it,
right?
Like,
so when people.
I think that maybe you talked about this
in the last podcast,
but uh,
when people first started imagining
mechanical devices to carry you around
mechanical transportation in the late 18
hundreds,
they imagined a mechanical horse cause
they knew the horse has existed,
right?
And the car was a totally different
thing and people hadn't thought of that
originally.
And then when people did think of cars,
they thought of flying cars because they
solved there were flying animals,
right?
And the flying cars haven't appeared
because w,
w we didn't what they should have been
thinking about it.
How are cars going to change our cities
and our commutes and how we live,
right?
Uh,
when people invented the Internet that
were,
they weren't sure what they were going
to do with it.
And I think that the same thing is true
when,
if we can imagine blending the barrier
between our biological existence in some
virtual existence,
we don't even know what questions to ask
about that.
Yeah.
And I think we are getting close to
those other things that you mentioned
though.
Boston dynamics is getting really close
to artificial dogs and artificial
horses.
I mean,
they have things that you can't kick,
you kick them and they,
they don't get knocked over and open
doors.
Yes.
They can jump like incredible distances,
incredible heights.
Um,
there's,
there's some amazing ones that do
acrobatics now.
We've seen that where they're going to
replace stuntman in movies that could
potentially get harmed with these robots
that can do crazy back flips and jump
off buildings and the next big war is
going to look very,
very different than very weird.
Right.
That's,
hopefully it won't happen,
but if it does,
yeah,
it's gonna.
There's a big emphasis on automated
things.
Not just drones,
but physical things that are running
around on the grass and make decisions
that.
Give it a little bit of Ai.
Then.
Do you watch dark mirror?
Uh,
I haven't seen it,
you know,
does it make in my queue?
There's an insane episode on.
Do you remember the name of it?
The one with Black Mirror,
black mirror.
That's a dark mirror.
Black Mirror is insane episode on these
little robots that are chasing metal
face,
metal head,
something like that.
Yeah,
it's about a robots chasing after this
lady.
And it's,
it literally is these little tiny Boston
dynamic robots,
but they can kill you and they're there
on a mission and this is not outside the
realm of possibility at all.
Nope.
It really isn't.
And like I said,
it's,
we don't even know.
It's easy to extrapolate right ahead.
Just ordered the Sarah differences.
There it is.
That's from the episode.
It's a fantastic episode two.
There's so many good episodes of that
show.
Black Mirror is just amazing.
Yeah.
I guess start watched.
Um,
but that,
that's a concern.
I mean there's,
there's a real concern.
I mean we're,
we're doing it right now with drones,
you know,
if you talk to people that are really,
that have paid attention to studied
drone warfare and how incredibly
inhumane it is and how different it is
from any other type of warfare in terms
of is like the ability to rationalize
targets when you're not there yet.
And you're,
you have,
you're nowhere near and you're just
pressing buttons and you decide
like little bell does a very good
possibility.
This person's in here.
Fuck it.
Nuke the building.
Yeah.
And we're,
I think we're doing that.
Yes,
absolutely happening.
But on the other hand,
the drones are also delivering pizzas.
Are they though?
I got a pizza with a drone thing.
So if you looked at the amount of people
that have delivered pizzas with drones
versus the amount of people that have
been killed by drones,
especially killing is bigger.
Well,
the innocence of the scariest drones are
really good at killing innocent people.
Not so good at killing the people that
are specific target targets.
But I think my,
my point is just that,
uh,
there are going to be pluses and
minuses,
right?
So I think that it's going to change.
Like if we,
if we combine this idea of,
you know,
interfacing with computers with this
idea of drones,
doing some drugs,
rework with this idea of giving people a
basic income.
Everyone is just going to sit in their
rooms and then write on their.
Tumblr is all day.
That's gonna be the future.
I don't think they're going to be
writing anymore.
I think this is a real possibility that
we're going to create virtual reality
that's indistinguishable from regular
reality.
And people are going to live in,
they're like ready player,
one will be better kind of thing.
I think that the big flaw to me and
things like trauma and are ready player
one is that they make the virtual
reality look too much like the real
reality.
There's no reason why virtual reality
has to have gravity.
There's no reason why it has to be three
dimensional.
There's no reason why.
You know you have any limit on how
strong you are,
how fast you are,
and if.
Yeah,
like there's no reason why you have to
have only one body.
I mean there's a million different ways
in which it could be very,
very different.
Well,
it also can be implemented with
something like the tank,
the float tank that we were talking
about earlier.
I mean you could climb into that float
tank with some sort of apparatus.
Hook these gloves on,
put this helmet over,
and literally not be subject to the
whims of gravity.
You can't even feel it.
Effects of gravity will be
inconsequential because you will feel
like you're floating.
And then from there you'll be able to
fly around.
And do all sorts of,
yeah,
I think like this weird period between,
you know,
the year 1900 and 2000 or 2000,
100 or whatever it's going to be a,
it'll be a weird transitional period in
human history where we invented
technology and not really put it to work
yet and there might be some equilibrium
that we reach and 100 or 200 years where
the whole mode of life is utterly
different than what it is now.
If you could put priorities in terms of
like what you think people should
concentrate on first when in regards to
this kind of stuff,
what do you think those would be like if
someone said,
Shawn,
you're a super smart dude.
Let's,
uh,
let's get on the ball here,
figure out what direction should we take
this in.
I mean,
what I do for living is more like
foundational.
What are the laws of physics kind of
thing.
Right?
So I'm not the person to speculate on
this stuff,
but.
Well,
I think,
um,
this is why I said earlier like I think
we should be talking to each other
because nobody is,
no one person is right.
Like that's why we need to have people
from different areas of expertise talk
about each other's areas if only then to
be corrected,
right?
But you know,
to be open to that dialogue.
So I think that for example,
an enormous amount of effort has been
put into nanotechnology building tiny
little machines.
I suspect that mostly the real,
uh,
advances,
they are not going to be in
nanotechnology,
but in synthetic biology where you take
bacteria are multicellular organisms
that already exists and adapt them for
your purposes,
make them do whatever you want.
Because biology has already solved a lot
of the problems that a technology is
still struggling to figure out.
So the concept of nanotechnologies
you're going to take like almost like a
cell sized machine,
right?
And many of them going to go into your
body and find areas that are damaged or
whatever.
Yeah,
there's a woman,
a professor at Caltech who gave a talk a
few months ago about tea builds robots
out of DNA,
so they're these little DNA robots can
go in and right now they're at the level
where what they can do is sort thing.
So like if they have a molecule one and
molecule to scattered across some
surface,
this little DNA robot will go in and
we've all molecule one to the left,
all of molecule due to the right and so
she says that's the beginning.
Like in the future you'll have your
little DNA box and you'll say,
you know,
I'm allergic to tomatoes,
and then it will invent a little machine
that will run through your body and fix
your allergy tomatoes.
Right?
You don't need that anymore with a
machine with a DNA robots.
So it's literally.
So why DNA,
because you think of DNA is carrying the
genetic code,
but DNA is a wonderful molecule because
it is relatively stable,
but it's not just a crystal,
right?
It's not just doing the same thing over
and over again.
So it contains information and it can
adapt.
It can.
It can,
you know,
uh,
hold on and grab onto certain things and
let go and,
and do things.
So DNA is a wonderful testing ground for
building little really,
really tiny things in your body that
will change who you are.
Here's a question that's not totally
related,
but you might be a good person for this.
What is quantum computing now?
[inaudible] I keep hearing about this.
That's one of the big breakthroughs in,
in computers is going to be quantum
computing,
right?
I'm almost the right guy.
I'm not completed the color.
I actually did teach a course at Caltech
that involve quantum computing.
So I'm above average,
definitely the best,
but yeah.
So,
um,
so quantum mechanics,
this is the book that I'm writing right
now,
uh,
that's gonna be a year from now called
something deeply hidden.
It'll be about quantum mechanics and the
goal of the book will be to make quantum
mechanics understandable to everybody
and convinced them that quantum
mechanics really does imply the
existence of multiple worlds where
things look very much the same except
for tiny differences.
And one way of thinking that will
quantum mechanics says is in classical
mechanics,
which is what came before quantum
mechanics.
Let's imagine you have a bit right?
That is something is either zero or one
right?
One piece of information.
In quantum mechanics,
you have a quantum bit accubid as they
call it,
very clever.
So the difference is that instead of it
being a zero or a one,
like it would be classically quantum,
mechanically,
it is in some super position of zero and
one and some combination of a little bit
zero,
a little bit one.
And it's not that you don't know which
one it is,
it's that it really is both.
It might be 90 percent zero and 10
percent one or something like that.
So take that fact number one fact number
two is the quantum mechanics has the
thing called entanglement,
which means that if you have two bits
classically,
so you have zero,
zero,
one,
one zero,
four different possibilities.
So quantum mechanics says it's not that
this one bit is in a combination of zero
and one,
and this other bit is also in a
combination of zero and one,
it's that the two bit system is in a
combination of zero,
zero,
one,
one zero,
one one,
right?
So it might be that it's 50 percent
zero,
zero and 50 percent one one.
So you don't know what either bit is,
but he know they're the same,
right?
So that's entanglement.
So you take these two ideas that you
have a combination of Zeros and ones
rather than just one or the other and
the different bits can be entangled with
each other.
And then you just say,
well what is a computer?
A computer is something that takes bits
in,
does manipulations,
and spits out the answer,
right?
You solve problems,
you.
That's what's literally going on.
And your computer as a bunch of zeroes
and ones being pushed around.
So a quantum computer is pushing out a
bunch of cubits,
right?
Bunch of spinning particles or something
like that.
The spin of a particle that can either
be spinning clockwise or
counterclockwise is a cupid,
and so these particles can interact with
each other,
they can become entangled and you invent
a quantum algorithm,
right?
Like there's algorithms for finding the
area of a surface or something like
that.
Factoring large numbers,
you know,
solving the shortest distance between
two different points.
You can do this using the rules of
quantum mechanics instead of the rules
of classical mechanics and the belief
which is not yet 100 percent
established,
but we think is true is that there are
some problems that are really,
really hard to solve for a classical
computer,
which means that you can easily make the
problem long enough that it would take
the lifetime of the universe to solve it
on a classical computer which quantum
computers can solve quite quickly and
efficiently.
And so it's.
We're not,
we haven't proven that it's not a
mathematically why.
Why would they think that quantum
computers will be able to solve it
quicker?
There's more information in the quantum
computer,
like if you have two bits,
zero,
one,
etc.
There's only four things that can be
right if you have a quantum computer is
an infinite number of things it can be
because it's any combination of those
four things,
right?
Ten percent this,
20 percent that.
So There's like a continuum of
possibilities.
It's,
it's analog rather than digital in some
sense.
And so what you,
what you can do,
you know,
the,
the quantum computer can just sort of
take advantage of that extra power,
um,
to look,
I mean,
because of this entanglement,
what this is,
this is I'm going to get in trouble with
my quantum computing friends because not
quite fair,
but roughly speaking rather than
manipulating bit by bit because of the
entanglement between the bits.
The quantum computer can move all the
bits a little bit at once.
So let's say that you're,
you're searching for something in the
list,
right?
A very elementary,
a computer science program is,
I'm giving you a list.
find an element that is equal to a
certain number,
right?
It sounds easy,
but if that list is 10 trillion things
long,
that's hard.
Right?
So what the quantum computer can do is
say,
take every element in the list,
nudge it a little bit towards zero if
it's the wrong answer in towards one if
it's the right answer and you don't know
where it is in the list,
but you can do that nudging over and
over again.
At the end of the day,
you look for where's the one it's very
easy to find so you can get the answer
much quicker.
It is believed.
and so things like cryptography,
privacy,
right or dramatically changed by this
because if one of the things that we
think quantum computers should be able
to do faster is factor large numbers,
which is the,
the,
the difficulty in factoring large
numbers is the basis for much modern
cryptography,
uh,
but also simulating systems that were
just too difficult to simulate,
you know,
just,
just took too much computer power to do
it.
Now maybe we can do it because nature is
truly quantum mechanical.
At the core,
it turns out to be very hard because the
problem is you have all these bits.
If you touch one of them,
if the outside world bumps into one of
them,
right,
like a cosmic ray or adam hits it,
the whole entanglement is ruined between
everything.
So it's very,
very delicate and that's what the,
you know right now,
um,
they're,
they're working on systems of let's say
dozens of cubits entangled at once.
You would,
you would like it to be way more than
that because you can store an enormous
amount of information in these things
and uh,
if it works as I think it'll be way
better at computing if it works.
I'm not at all sure that quantum
computers will be efficient or cost
effective or anything like that in the
near term.
But you know,
doing computations faster or something
is a lot of people wouldn't be able to
do so right now they're working with
dozens of cubits and what's preventing
them from expanding that or they're
doing it slowly,
sort of make sure that it all works
correctly and get a,
an accurate model.
Yeah.
So the problem is if you had a cubit,
it can be in a combination of zero or
one,
right?
Any combination whatsoever,
but as soon as you look at it,
you never see the combination.
You see zero or you see one that's it
and you've ruined.
You've erased this preexisting
combination.
If you see zero,
now it's in the state zero c one,
it's in the state one.
So if you have a group of many,
many cubits,
what I mean by look at is literally
anything else in the world bumping into
it.
So like if,
like I said,
if photons headed,
if particles,
uh,
you know,
if,
if molecules of air and oxygen or
nitrogen bump into the cubit,
that'll count as an observation and it
will collapse as we say,
it collapses the wave function and then
all of your quantum information is
ruined.
So,
uh,
you have to make them a sort of very
cold,
very isolated,
very from external influences.
And the more cubits you add,
the harder that is to do well.
Now,
was there a proof of concept this?
Yep.
They have working quantum computers.
I forget.
There was a joke.
Scott aaronson,
who's a friend of mine who's a genius,
a theoretical computer scientist.
he used to joke that the quantum
computers are able to say that the
number 15 is equal to five times three
with very high probability.
That was the state of the art.
I think they're able to say that 21
equals three times seven with very high
probability now.
But,
uh,
what you would like to say is,
you know,
some hundred digit number is the product
of two other numbers not able to do that
right now.
Now,
what are they looking at with this and
when they're,
when they're looking at in terms of the
future,
this stuff,
what are the,
how do they want to implement this?
Lots of different ways actually,
like the actual physical technology that
they're using.
Some people are using adam's,
some people are using sort of um,
uh,
features of condensed matter systems
like two dimensional systems where
electrons are moving slowly and can wind
around each other and things like that.
ThiS is way beyond what I actually know
about,
but also this sort of side light of this
is that this existence of entanglement,
um,
it's kind of a shared information
between two different things.
In a way that classical physics just
would not allow,
and that's interesting and exciting
because it opens up ways,
uh,
for,
for sharing information that other
people can't get to because you have
some information.
Your friend has some information,
but it's,
it,
you need both pieces of it to get to it.
Right.
I'm seth lloyd,
who's another friend of mine at mit,
professor said that he was,
he tells a story where he was in a hot
tub with the google guys,
right with sergey and larry and you
know,
the heads of google,
the founders,
and he said,
oh,
I came up with this brilliant new idea
where we can use quantum mechanics build
a quantum computer so that a person who
does a search,
a google search using this quantum
computer,
they can do a search and they can get
their answer,
but it is literally impossible for
anyone else to ever know what they
searched for.
And the google guys are like very
excited and they went away.
The next day they came back and said,
oh,
we realized this is the opposite of our
business model.
It's really important to us that we know
what he's right.
That's the whole thing with them.
Google ads,
google ad sense.
When you go to another website,
it's shows you,
oh,
sean's been looking at,
you know,
lenovo laptops and they follow you
around and all your other devices,
your cookies.
Creepy.
But yeah,
so In quantum in quantum computing is
there's quantum money,
there's quantum cryptography,
there's quantum eavesdropping,
things like that.
So it's just,
uh,
it's,
it's easy to speculate about.
I would not say the actual technology is
very far advanced right now,
but I can't tell you how quickly.
Why wouldn't someone like google just
have to adjust?
Because prior to these google ads,
you'd never really knew what someone was
interested in unless they took
surveys or unless they had purchasing
history.
are there had to be some way that you
could now that just detecting off of
searches and that's what their business
model is.
That doesn't mean they can't come up
with a better new business model.
They will have to adapt,
but they are not in the business of
making that happen.
No stAte now.
It's so effective.
If they were really smart,
they would have given $100,000 and they
didn't tell no one about this ever
again.
Is that enough?
Yeah.
we found out what the stormy daniels
case.
That hundred thousand dollars doesn't
buy a lot of two thirds of a stormy
daniel.
What do you think they'll like?
What will be the first way they try to
use something like this?
They try to use quantum computing.
I don't know.
I think that,
um,
you know,
the people who are really interested in
now are,
uh,
the nsa in the dod,
right?
A national security agency and the
department of defense because secret
messages are the most obvious thing.
I'm cracking codes and things like that.
That's like the killer app that we know
about right now.
I'm a physicist.
Of course,
when you use it to simulate quantum
mechanical systems to learn about other
behavior materials,
like maybe you will build a better super
conductor or something like that right
away.
Maybe you'll do better designing of your
genetically engineered dna on a quantum
computer.
Right?
Like there's sort of the generic thought
that you'll be able to do computations
faster.
That's interesting.
Then there's more specific things like
if the system you're trying to simulate
is itself quantum mechanical than
simulating it on a quantum computer
might be the way to go.
Yeah.
To most people that just were woo right
over their head.
What is,
what are these guys?
The quantum is so weird.
Like one of the things that you said
earlier,
you were,
when you were talking about quantum,
you were talking about worlds that are
very similar but with very small
differences,
right?
Yes.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I forget whether we talked about this
last time.
Um,
but you know,
so there's this whole version of
quantum.
Well let me,
let me back up because we.
okay,
right.
Sure.
Quantum mechanics is weird because among
other things it is by far the most
successful theory of physics ever
invented.
We've tested it to enormous precision,
right?
There's zero evidence.
Quantum mechanics is in any way not
right,
but we don't understand it.
We don't,
we are not just people in the street
like professional physicists don't know
exactly what quantum mechanics says,
so how do you practice it?
Well,
we have a recipe.
We have a black box,
right?
The way that I,
I put it in the book is imagine you had
a website you could go to and you would
say,
you know,
if I threw a ball with certain velocity
in a certain direction,
how far would it go?
And it will give you the answer right
away depending upon.
Does that.
Yeah.
Did you put all the details and it gives
you the answer.
Does that count as you knowing the laws
of physics,
you know?
No.
You just have a black box,
right?
Well that's what quantum mechanics is
right now.
If we set up an experiment,
we can say what the probability of every
answer is going to be every outcome,
but if you say,
well,
why?
What happened?
We don't know,
or we don't agree like different people
disagree with each other and so this
version of quantum,
there's different that try to answer
this question,
what's really going on beneath the
surface?
Right?
What's what's the deep down story of the
world and one of these stories is the
many worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics and it was invented by a
graduate student,
whoever in the 19 fifties who was
instantly kicked out of physics because
really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That is a long unglorious history of
people trying to think deeply about
quantum mechanics and being shunned in
the community for doing so because we've
set up this weird thing where,
I mean,
there was literally a memo that went
around the major physics journal.
The United States said we will not even
look at papers that try to think about
the foundations of quantum mechanics.
Uh,
it's embarrassing.
It's terrible.
It's like we need to do like real work,
like shut up and calculate,
you know,
we need to build bombs and things not
think about the nature of reality,
which I think is very much antithetical
to what physicists should be doing.
But anyway,
so many world says is,
well,
so what we.
When we do talk about quantum mechanics,
but let's say we have a cube and we have
a spinning particle,
right?
We have this combination of spinning
clockwise and counterclockwise,
and so we call that the wave function.
The wave function is just,
it's 10 percent clockwise,
2090 percent counter clockwise or
whatever.
So to every possible measurement
outcome,
you give me a number and that number is
basically how I figured out the
probability of that measurement outcome
coming true,
and that's the wave function.
So there for a long time people thought,
well,
this is just a trick.
This is just like some it,
it characterizes our inability to be
precise,
right?
We have a probability of this,
a probability of that,
but someday they hoped.
Einstein,
for example,
had this hope that we'll have a better
theory and we'll know exactly how to
predict everything with perfect
precision.
So whatever it says,
no,
no.
It's the other way around.
Um,
this wave function is reality.
That's the whole world,
right?
That's what reality is.
It is a superposition.
The combination of all the different
possible outcomes.
It's not any one outcome.
There's no such thing as where the
electron is,
it's all spread out.
And the problem with that is that when
you look at the electron spinning,
you never see It as a combination of
spinning clockwise and counterclockwise.
You always see one or the other and
everett says,
that's because you have a wave function.
You live as a superposition of different
possibilities.
And when you look at the electron,
what happens is before there was you and
there was an electron and a combination
of counterclockwise and clockwise,
afterward there is the electron was
spinning clockwise and spinning
clockwise plus that's 10 percent,
the 90 percent.
The electron was spinning
counterclockwise and you saw that
spinning counterclockwise and both
possibilities are real,
but they're separate.
They've branched off from each other,
they've gone their own ways.
There's separate versions of the world,
separate copies of reality.
That's why it's called the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics.
Possibilities is always a big feature.
That's the thing that people are
constantly discussing,
right?
What are the possibilities?
Predicting the possIbilities and when it
comes to human beings,
this is also randomly discussed because
we,
we talk about determinism versus
freewill.
We talk about what are the,
what,
what's created,
what are the possibilities that is
created as Sean Carroll and why?
Why do you think the way you think and
why are you going to say the next thing
you're going to say and is it,
how much of it is biological,
how much of it is your life experience,
how much of it is information that's
dancing in your head?
How much are you interacting with me?
The last thing that I've said to you.
Yeah,
so I had a.
I was on the same harris's podcast.
We had a long conversation about this
because he is very anti freewill and I
think that it's.
I,
I disagree with him but I don't care.
I think kind of boring to be honest,
as he was born.
I think it's boring because here's what
I think it's boring because there's two
questions.
One question is how does the world work?
And the other question is what words
should be attached to how the world
works and the first one is interesting
and the second one is kind of boring.
I see what you're saying.
I've seen seminar,
I agree on how the world works,
right?
But I am what philosophers call a
compatiblist when it comes to freewill,
which,
which is,
I don't think that I have some ways of
thinking my way into overcoming the laws
of physics,
right?
Like I'm made of atoms made,
uh,
particles that obey the laws of physics.
If I talk about myself as a large
collection of atoms and particles
obeying the laws of physics,
then clearly there's no free will.
There's just the solution to the
equations and sometimes the wave
function branches and there's now two of
me,
but that's whatever it is.
There's no spark of consciousness that
lets me overcome what the equation site
is going to happen.
But guess what?
That's not a fruitful way to go through
your life in terms of talking about
human beings.
When you meet somebody for the first
time and you say like,
you know,
what do you do?
Who are you?
They don't give you a list of their
atoms and say what every atom is doing
and say,
let you let go ahead and solve for
triggers equation to figure out what's
going to happen next.
Right?
You tell a story,
you say like you're a person,
you know you grew up in a certain place,
you have a certain jobs,
stuff like that.
You dramatically condense the
information about who you are into a few
salient points and among those salient
points are I am a person who thinks and
makes decisions.
Every person in the world,
no matter how anti-free will they are
talks about people as if they make
decisions and the reason they do is
because that's how people are.
That's the best way to talk about
people.
It's not like just a compromise,
like if you don't know the atoms and
molecules and somebody's body and you're
not infinitely computationally powerful,
so you can predict the future,
then it's correct to talk about people
as agents who make decisions.
We call that freewill.
I call that freewill.
Most philosophers call it free will.
If you don't want to call it freewill,
be my guest.
I don't really know,
it doesn't really matter to.
I agree with what you're saying.
I think that makes a lot of sense and I
think that really simplifies a very
complex issue.
I,
when I looked at it and I have had this
conversation with sam as well,
uh,
I totally see his point and I think he
makes 100 percent sense.
It's as,
there's no arguing with it.
I really think it's very rational that
approach.
But I also think that it's very much
like what we were talking about earlier,
that it's not necessarily just a one or
a zero,
but it's a combination of these things
freewill.
There has to,
there is some mechanism that chooses to
do one thing versus another.
There's some computation,
there's calculation,
there's debate,
there's discussion,
there's a thing inside of you.
Whatever it is,
whatever that process is that's causing
you to.
I mean,
how many times have people stayed up all
night going over and over and over a
certain idea of trying to find a
rational conclusion.
Oh yeah.
All right,
well what is that?
Is that,
is that,
this is where the,
it actually becomes interesting to talk
about the vocabulary we use,
right?
Because it becomes very,
very hard to know where to attach the
word.
I or you,
when you're talking about this,
we tend to say I made a decision.
Okay,
that's fine.
Right?
I decided to have this can have pure
caffeine that you put in front of me and
drink it.
Um,
I could have decided otherwise.
So that's the question,
like does it make sense to say I could
have decided otherwise?
And if you define yourself as the
following list of atoms and particles in
a certain configuration,
then no.
Then the laws of physics said that that
was going to happen.
but I don't know what all that is.
That's not a useful way of talking.
So there's a whole nother way of talking
that says I'm a person and I kind of
like coffee,
but I already had a cup this morning and
you know,
there's a chance,
there's a probability,
like you say that I would drink this and
it probably that I would not.
And those are completely compatible.
Although they're different,
the only way you get into trouble is if
you mix up those two different ways of
talking.
If you say like I chose to have the
coffee because my atoms were following
configuration or something like that.
right.
That's like talking about us as humans
and then switching vocabulary.
He's talking about us as adams and
that's where you get in trouble.
Yeah.
It's a weird reductionist take on what
it means to be a person that thinks.
Yeah.
I think if you say there's no free will
in your adams,
then I'm with you.
I'm on board,
but no one in the world goes through
life that way for good reason and they
never will.
It's not going to happen.
Yeah.
Well he and you could break that all the
way down to creativity.
Right?
Like what?
When someone sits down and writes
something like where's all that coming
from?
Yeah.
So I think again,
there's feminism as well.
There is an interesting question about,
you know,
how much we will ultimately be able to
unpack and understand about that.
Right.
Right now the brain is kind of just a
mystery box to us and there's so much we
don't know about how people make
decisions,
how they remember things,
how they come up with new ideas,
so,
so where it matters is how we treat
people,
right?
Like the obvious case is responsibility.
Blame.
Like if,
if you think that a person makes
choices,
then you can assign responsibility to
them for making the choices they made.
Yes.
That's what we do in the world.
If someone chooses to rob a bank,
we choose to put them in jail,
right?
And someone,
someone could come along and say,
no one ever does this,
but someone could come along and say,
well,
they're just a bunch of atoms obeying
laws of physics.
How can you blame them?
Right?
It will pop.
That doesn't make any sense,
but what if you were minority report,
right?
What if you could like put someone in an
mri in a brain scanner and say,
yeah,
you know what?
Tomorrow they're gonna rob a bank.
Do you arrest them?
Is that,
is that enough?
Right.
The fact that their brain was hooked up
to a to violate the law and the future,
is that enough to sign personal
responsibility to them for that or do
you more do you do the opposite and say,
well,
it's going to happen no matter what.
We can't really blame them.
Well,
and also if you do catch this thought
process is before the actual action
takes place,
isn't impossible to correct that thought
process with education or some sort of
awareness training or something where
you could shift the consciousness and
abruptly sort of disassembled
determinism at its most problematic
point.
Yeah,
so there's a.
There's a whole kind of a interesting
set of ideas that are very popular among
philosophers right now,
which is the question of moral luck.
Oh,
so if you're driving down the street and
you're buzzed,
you're drunk,
right?
maybe you get home,
fine.
Maybe someone jumped in front of your
car and you run them over because you
don't have the agility or the reflexes
because you're drunk.
Right?
So you're the same person.
You went home,
you're drunk and you're driving home,
but depending on the outside world,
you ran someone over and killed them
where you didn't,
but in the world we blame the person who
ran somebody over.
We,
we punish them much more severely than
the person who got home safely.
Right.
That's not their responsibility.
They sort of got unlucky there in the
world.
So should we blame people who had the
chance of doing it?
No one knows the answer to these
questions.
These are,
these are tricky things.
Like we're not very good.
We human beings at the thing about these
probabilistic counterfactual questions.
Yeah.
That's a good one.
That is.
Yeah.
Hmm.
What,
who are you then?
Yeah.
You lucky.
Oh yeah.
Right.
I mean,
so much of what happens to us in life we
don't get responsibility for,
for interfacing with random next every
time we step out the door.
That's right.
But,
uh,
can you treat people that way
consistently?
It's hard,
right?
It's tricky.
I'm not giving the answer because I
don't know.
Yeah.
this is,
this is tricky stuff.
We're certainly not like if you lived in
a world where you thought that what
happened in the world was preordained
that there was all the great playing out
as a master plan or at the very least,
that there was some sort of a karmic
influence that made good things happen
to good people,
bad things happen to bad people.
Then the world makeS more sense,
right?
Yeah.
I don't believe
any of that stuff,
but at least then the world seems if,
if there's something random,
you can attach a reason why it happens.
There seems to be something to karma in
that when you do good things,
you make people feel better,
they feel about you better,
and then they interface with you in a
more positive way and that sort of like
has this outgoing effect that's not
karma.
That's just a smart thing to do.
Yeah.
No,
I think that you're right,
that we,
and maybe this is just sort of a western
post enlightenment way of thinking,
we tend to sort of think about immediate
consequences for our actions for better,
for worse,
and in the real world sort of generally
trying to be good can often pay back in
good ways,
but the woo woo thing is that we're
putting out this good energy and good
energy is coming back to us and it's a
fun way to look at things.
Although there's no evidence that points
to it.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like if I'm in a yoga class and my yoga
instructor is talking about different
energy flowing through different chakras
or whatever,
I don't care.
like it doesn't bother me as long as it
makes me,
you know,
do that exercise.
There's a players a little bit,
but I'm not going to speak up,
let's put it that way.
Right.
Of course you're not going to stop the
class.
You're telling bullshit.
I would rather have that than you know,
if people want to come up with an excuse
to be a good person,
that's okay.
It's funny that yoga class is always the
base.
That's always where people go to talk
about like we're,
we're woo comes from.
Yeah.
It's,
it's there.
Because I've had,
you know,
I mean if you've done yoga,
like there's a whole spectrum,
right?
Like there's teAchers who are basically
just physical therapists and there are
people who are complete crazy hippies,
you know,
you have to think the right thoughts,
you know?
Yeah.
But people are always searching for some
understanding of really complex issues
and behavior is very complex issue.
Sure.
Behavior and how you feel like whether
you feel good,
we,
you feel spiritually enriched,
whether you feel positive about
humanity,
like the,
all these things are like which what was
trying to manipulate these states,
whether it's through meditation and
mindfulness training,
trying to figure out a way to positively
interface,
you know,
it's true.
And it goes back to where we started
talking about youtube comments because
like I said,
I do react badly to bed too stupid.
Youtube,
well you're a human being.
Well,
I'm a human being,
but I think,
and I think that the internet does a
magnifying,
some of our bad tendencies,
right?
And I think that,
you know,
among these and until I totally include
myself as a bad actor here in the sense
that it's just so easy to be sarcastic
and put people down and,
you know,
uh,
dIsagree in sort of dismissive ways.
I don't think that's good.
I would like to live in a world where
people,
including myself,
even when we disagree with people,
even when we disagree with people who
are stupid and we're not trying to
engage them or improve
their lives,
just,
you know,
get on with our own lives rather than
trying to have a snarky comeback.
like I get that there's a purpose to
snark and sarcasm and whatever,
but it weighs you down.
Right?
This is why people complain about
twitter and social media,
like it's so much psychic energy just
gets sapped by reading.
All oF these complaints on either side
has no political bias,
right?
Like whatever your feelings are,
someone else is making you feel down on
the internet somewhere.
and it does weigh on you.
There's also,
there's weird impulse that people have
with whether it's social,
whether it's twitter or youtube
comments.
This is reductionist take on things to
reduce a person down to maybe one
statement or misinterpretations of one
position and then have that person be
dismissed.
Yeah.
And I,
I think,
yeah,
and it's a tough play.
I have,
after thinking about it a little bit,
I think that it was a bad decision that
james gunn got fired,
for example.
I don't know if you've followed that,
that little thing.
Guardians of the galaxy,
the galaxy guy.
Well those were really bad tweets.
Oh yeah.
They just
weren't funny and he wrote a bunch of
them and they were a
lot,
a lot of,
a lot of about pedophilia.
So I totally get it right.
I'm not shocked that he got in trouble
that way,
but I also think that his response was
immediate,
incorrect,
and grownup.
He said he didn't say like,
oh,
I was young.
It was a different time.
He says,
oh yeah,
I did that.
It was shitty and it was wrong.
And I take responsibility.
And I do think we got to let people
grow,
right?
Like that's what most people in this
sort of post mi do era have not done
when they've been accused of these
things.
They haven't taken responsibility.
They've made made excuses.
And I think that a,
on twitter,
especially twitter,
I think it's my favorite social media,
but,
um,
it is too easy to be reductive.
It's too easy to be simplistic and to
respond.
And you're one of,
one of the things that annoys me the
most about twitter is when someone tries
to be good and then 20 other people say,
well,
you're not being good in precisely the
right way.
I,
even though I failed to live up to it
myself,
I'm trying to be better.
I want to be charitable when I deal with
other people.
I got in trouble on twitter the other
day for defending kellyanne conway a
little bit.
What did she do well,
years ago?
She did the alternative facts thing.
Remember when she said when they were
talking about the inauguration crowd and
people pointing out like,
no,
that's just factually incorrect.
And she says,
well,
there are alternative facts.
So like,
I don't want to defend kellyanne conway,
I'm not a defender of her in general.
Um,
but I think that she just misspoke that
one time.
I think that what she was trying to say
was there are additional facts that we
could also look at.
Right?
And of course that's in a bigger context
where she lies all the time and she,
you know,
uh,
let's other people,
she is an apologist for other liars.
But I,
you know,
I think that the idea that these people
who I disagree with politically are so
divorced from reality that they think
they can just make up their own reality.
No one actually thinks that way.
Like the people who,
you know,
the people who disagree with me about
politics or religion or whatever,
it's comforting for me to think that
they are,
you know,
just cheerfully making up facts and
reality by them selves.
They don't think of themselves that way.
They think that they're being truthful.
They think of they're being rational,
incorrect.
And so I should at least grant them that
that's what they think in their own
right.
Well,
I'm going to disagree with you on that
because I don't think that,
first of all,
I don't think that she's granted any
sort of autonomous decision making
capabilities.
And I think this is probably something
that was sat down that they sat down
with a team of experts or you know,
air quote experts,
team of people that were in that,
in that you know,
room,
whether it's press,
people are spin doctors where they're
trying to figure out a best way to get
out of this.
And one of the best ways was this
concept of alternative facts.
Very similar to the.
One of the ways where trump was in that
meeting with putin at very famous awful
meeting that happened recently where he
said,
I don't see any reason why it would be
Russia that's interfering.
And then he said afterwards,
obviously I misspoke.
I thought it was clear what I meant to
say.
I didn't see any reason why wouldn't be.
I shouldn't say.
But it's clear if you watch him say it.
Yeah.
That's not what he sells.
Entirely bullshit,
entirely bullshit,
dangerous bullshit,
but I think gary bullshit in my opinion.
Yes,
it's,
it's such a lie.
Right?
In,
in context,
the way he's expressing himself and it's
clearly he's dismissing it.
Like why would it be,
why would it be Russia?
He's not saying why wouldn't it be
Russia because he's standing right next
to putin and he would be saying that in
a much more measured and you would be.
It would be accusing.
Yeah.
That was clearly a case where he did
something really bad and he came home
and all of his advisors said that we
have to fix this little bit and they
came up with a really clumsy,
you know,
incredibly.
That's all they had.
Right.
Because it's so blatant,
right?
Alternative facts is also all that.
I don't.
Well,
I.
You might be right.
Actually,
you know what?
I didn't really study it very carefully.
I think that it was just a spontaneous
blurting out a be my favorite too,
because here's why.
I think that that's probably right
because I don't think I was trying to
say before,
I don't think that's their
self-conception.
Like people often think that the people
that they disagree with a think false
things,
that's very natural,
but they also also like uncharitable he
say they know their thinking false
things and they're,
you know,
they're,
they're happily making up their own
version of reality.
And I think that's very rare.
I think that happens,
like if you're just a con man or
whatever,
but I think that more often than we
wanted to admit people are sincere in
their very false beliefs.
Right.
So I,
so I just find it implausible that,
uh,
I mean kellyanne conway again lies all
the time.
That is not my defense for my defense of
hers.
It was just that she would not go out
there and say,
oh yes,
but we're making up new facts.
That's just not the kind of thing.
Something,
it's.
She didn't say it that way
where she said,
there are all turned art.
There are alternative facts.
Now you got to think that he's playing
to the dumbest people in the room all
the time and fortunately for him that's
a big number.
Yeah,
and there's a recent thing where he was
defending his behavior saying that
anyone can act presidential and he stood
on stage and he did this sort of like
robotic,
boring walk back and forth,
and then he started talking in a boring
way and mocking it.
And what's interesting about the video
is not just him doing this,
which is very silly,
but it's also the people behind him
thinking it's hilarious.
These nazi this.
Yeah.
See if he could find it.
There's a video of him saying that he,
uh,
anyone can act presidential.
This is very,
very recently and a lot of people were
watching this going what?
But he alSo thinks you need id to buy
groceries.
Yeah,
there's a lot of that.
There's.
well,
he also thinks that stealth bombers are
invisible.
Yeah,
I see that.
I can't see them.
You're right behind it,
asshole.
You can look at it.
Do you follow a kellyanne conway's
husband on twitter?
Do you know who he is?
George conway.
He's a lawyer and he's like,
like very vocally anti-trump.
It's hilarious.
He's constantly subtweeting and like,
you know,
making fun of trump.
Yeah.
Interesting.
That's going to be fun.
Fun household,
but what's.
This is what gets me go full screen in
this gulf.
You can't.
What's interesting is these dummies
behind him.
Yeah.
Like while this is happening,
one of the interesting things about this
to me is that his back is to all these
people,
which is a very odd.
Right?
So they're all
behind him instead of having a static
backdrop.
You,
you're getting to a part of the thing is
the other people.
It's not just him,
it's their reactions.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a sense of belonging to a weird
group.
Yeah.
And everyone has that,
like leftist and rightness and whatever.
All have this weird belonging.
But when it's.
Again,
it goes back to the China thing,
right?
Well,
we have fox news.
We have a way of giving people
information that if you follow.
I follow fox news on twitter because I
want to see what they're telling people.
It's a weird thing because it's not like
it's all lies,
right?
There's,
there's often lies,
they're there,
but it's like a very different mixture
of things than you would get from
the rest of the media and a lot of it
is,
it's very clear if you,
if you follow fox news,
like they're,
they're targeting an older white,
a rural suburban audience.
Right.
So there's a lot of like weird human
interest stories about an alligator
popping out of the sewer and things like
that,
like things that are not there.
They have no political agenda,
but they're just trying to get those old
white people to pay attention.
Yeah.
Well they're sending a message that the
world is kinda scary and weird and you
know,
we need to protect ourselves and then
later on the golf course,
they really.
Yeah,
like they love those stories,
right.
The alligator,
the golf courses is my favorite.
It's just local news at 10:00,
local news put,
you know,
a nationwide and edit in there with some
cheerleading for this bizarrely
dysfunctional administration.
Well isn't sean hannity now the number
one watch cable news program or
something like that?
Yeah,
I don't know the number.
I think it's number one and it's fucking
off.
They just,
they just,
there was just a poll.
This goes back to the social credit
thing.
They did a poll.
What is the most trusted news source?
Um,
and fox news gave me number two.
What's number one?
Bbc.
That makes sense.
We'll cnn.
It's just taken a giant hit because of
his constant,
constant berating of them.
And then you see jim acosta,
you know,
the whole,
these,
all these pro wrestling fans like giving
them the finger and screaming at him.
And it's what I do worry that this is a
hard thing to come back from because you
know,
once you know,
one another thing that trump said was
that,
you know,
don't believe anything you're told,
right?
Unless you hear it from me.
And he says the same thing now.
Sorry,
tucker carlson said the same thing,
right?
He say that to tucker carlson said like
any other shows in this one,
don't believe it.
Yeah.
Look at this.
Fuck the media he has on women for
trump.
It's just.
And then after listening to this radio
lab podcast about these russian troll
farms and about how they implement these
things,
you got to think,
is all of this organic is how many of
how much of this is orchestrated?
How much of this attacking cnn is
orchestrated?
It's part of it is part of it is just it
builds on itself.
All you need is just a little bit of a
push.
Just talking to someone who is a who is
boasting about how hard to Donald Trump
works that like compared to previous
presidents,
he's really just putting in the hours
that you could think of that he wakes
up,
lady watches eight hours of tv every
day.
He spends all the time at his own
resorts,
like of all the fantasies you could
invent.
That's a very weird one.
Well,
people just love to find narratives of
fit.
What would be acceptable for their
opinions.
So this side that they've taken.
Exactly right.
Yeah.
And so he's,
you know,
he give him credit,
he gives people a narrative that works
for them.
Well,
cnn does it too because cnn,
they,
they spent so little time,
uh,
going over donner,
brazil's book about how the dnc had been
corrupted and about how they had rigged
the primaries for hillary and really
screwed bernie sanders over.
This is not a narrative that they
dwelled on.
They didn't dwell on the fact that she
illegally deleted 30 plus thousand
emails and said they were about yoga
classes.
Like that shit is just as preposterous.
It's just as.
It's just as damning against cnn as some
of the nonsense that fox news does.
There's no one pure organization of news
that's holy object.
It's not just as I.
I think that fox news is a special,
especially damning.
I think it talks,
I mean fox news was founded by a guy who
was a political operative for the
republican party,
right?
Like there might,
like individual reporters for most news
organizations tend to be liberal,
but they also sometimes tend to
overcorrect for that.
Like to try to bend over backwards to be
fair,
like way more republicans are quoted in
New York times and democrats ever.
And I think that there are certainly
biases and certainly I'm a
misrepresentation of reality from all of
these different outlets,
but I think fox news is special among
the major ones.
I would,
I would concede that.
But I also think that one example of the
New York times is different because the
New York times,
I feel like because of the fact that
it's actually writers and it's in text,
you're not dealing with people that have
to be comfortable performing in front of
a camera,
which eliminates a large swath of
intellectuals.
Right.
It's a very different medium.
It's definitely they fact check and a
carnival corrections in a way that the.
The tv does not yet.
Yeah,
it's theater.
It's a different thing.
And the people like sean hannity that if
you read his written word,
I don't think he would stand out.
No.
And I.
And again,
like I said this before,
I worry about what happens next because
I don't think that trump will win again.
I think you will.
All right.
I don't think it's entirely possible
he'll win again.
Yeah,
it would be.
But again,
I didn't think he was going to win the
first one she was going to say,
don't listen to me.
Like before Donald Trump,
I was really good at predicting who's
going to win elections and I have no
ability once he's in the game.
So.
But I,
I worry that the people who sort of are
on his side are going to feel even more
disenfranchised,
disenchanted and angry after he loses
again than they do now.
And that's,
that's gonna be a problem.
I think that's a real fear.
And I think that one of the reasons why
I said it's entirely possible and I
don't know if he will win again,
but I don't even know if I believe he'll
do it again.
But I think it's a possibility.
And I think that one of the reasons why
I think that is I don't see who's the
big candidate on the other side.
It's opposing him.
That stands out right now.
Yeah,
that's a problem.
I think there's a real issue with people
not wanting the job.
it's a really scary job.
You know it,
it sucks you dry like a vampire that's
hooked up to the back of your neck is
just so even with him with his unique
ability to sociopathically sort of
navigate the waters of accusations and
guilt,
he still looks beaten down by this job.
Yeah,
but people want it.
Maybe not the people we want to want it.
Right.
Who sit on the democrat side,
who wants it on the left?
That stands out.
I mean,
I think I'm not excited by any of the
people right now,
but the whole one is.
I bet there's going to be 10 people
running at least.
I mean,
I think the biden is at least a 50
percent chance to run.
Elizabeth warren's definitely going to
run a with warren though.
She's got that real problem with the
whole pocahontas thing.
Well the whole indian thing,
that narrative and then what are you
going to win?
Right.
But that,
that is a giant problem.
The thing that she may have faked
whether or not she has native american
heritage and she's not willing to take a
dna test and there's this native
american heritage she claimed is how she
got into harvard and she.
She used that in order to get special
status and that's a problem.
You know,
whether or not you should forgive
someone for something they did a long,
long time ago,
which I think you probably should.
The problem is it's sort of in some ways
negates a lot of the good work and
things that she said because people say,
I can't trust her.
She lied about her actual ethnicity.
Yeah,
it's.
But what is hard for me to do is to
predict how much it will matter.
Right.
Like in 2008,
we had a race between Vietnam war hero
and a black guy.
He was middle name was hussein.
Right.
If you had told me that a few years
earlier,
who's going to win?
I would have gotten that one.
We also had sarah pailin,
I think.
Exactly.
This is what we don't know had taken a
better running mate.
It's entirely possible.
Mccain would've been president,
I think that people were really tired of
george w and I think that um,
mccain was just not a good candidate.
I think he was gonna lose no matter
what.
But I think also obama was so
charismatic and so uniquely intelligent
and smooth and relaxed and statesmen
like,
I think he,
he fit the bill and remember on a
depressed,
worried about like he went to jeremiah
rights church and things like that,
right.
Stuff that didn't like at the time it
was a big deal and you know,
who cares eight years later.
So I don't know about the pocahontas
stuff.
That's not,
that's a big one though.
The pocahontas stuff is a big one
because it's a personal lie.
I don't know.
But again,
I mean I think cory booker is going to
run camela harris might run,
who knows?
There's a bunch of people.
I would not be at all surprised that joe
biden didn't run and I kind of don't
think that he should,
but he's getting up there and he's in
Washington insider,
which is not really what the country
wants.
Right.
In 1988 in boston,
we used to have joe biden night at the
comedy clubs and joe biden night was a
night where we would do other people's
material because this is when joe biden
busted.
Yeah,
with kennedy's speeches.
Yeah.
Well,
and neil connect the british politician
and was when he was running for
president in [inaudible] 88.
Right.
And so we've never done very well
running for president.
He's won several times.
It's so I'm,
I think that he was a good vice
president to people like him for that
and they might not want them to do more
than the vice president is a great job.
She want no one to pay attention to you.
YeAh,
exactly.
It's like being the,
the,
you know,
the costar and a buddy cop movie with a
huge super theory responsibilities.
Go to some funerals.
Yeah.
Easy.
Unless you're mike pence where you're
trying to make it the handmaid's tale
behind the scenes.
He seems like he's kind of laying back
though,
like especially over the last few months
like that.
Trump is so insane that you see very
little mike.
I don't think you see very little of
him,
but I think that he's trying his best to
put in policies behind the scenes.
Well,
um,
what is this new thing that jeff
sessions is trying to push?
Religious freedom.
Yes.
which means you have to obey whatever
the fundamentalist christians want to
do.
Yeah.
Well,
this is what,
you know,
michael mouse was tweeting about this
the other day when,
when he,
he,
he tweeted this,
he said,
when I said that aversion of sharia law
could very well be coming out of this
administration.
This is what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a weird backward thing where you
define religious freedom to be let
fundamentalist christians do whatever
they want.
Right?
And do it by law.
Yeah.
I mean,
and it's,
it's tricky because,
uh,
yeah.
I don't know.
I mean if someone wants.
A part of me is a little bit libertarian
when it comes to personal action,
like if someone doesn't want to deal
with you,
that's their right.
But when whole groups are being subject
systematically to discrimination,
like gays are,
then the government steps in to protect
them a little bit and I think that's
okay.
And a lot of this is,
you know,
doctors don't want to do abortions or
health care providers,
insurance providers don't want to pay
for things because of their religious
beliefs or,
or catholic universities don't want to
do certain things.
And I think that,
uh,
these are legitimate questions and we're
not really having a grown up
intellectual conversation about them.
We're just throwing feces at each other.
You know,
in this particular arena.
Well,
it's also strange when someone comes up
with some sort of a new idea like that,
that goes against the separation of
church and state and it's being promoted
by a guy who's openly religious and says
about a bunch of really preposterous
things.
And you know,
generally someone who's not a very
trustworthy source of,
of intellectual discourse.
That's right.
And there's this,
there's this vaccinating question about
why a white depth angelicals or trump's
biggest support group like huge track,
despite the fact that he is not
religious himself,
that he's the biggest sinner ever to be
in the oval office.
Uh,
but they love hIm and it's,
it's a weird thing.
I think a lot of it comes well.
So there's,
there's sort of the strategic questions.
A lot of it comes down to abortion,
right?
They want supreme court justices will
overturn roe v dot wade,
that then whoever,
however they're going to get that is
good for them.
But then there's a whole much more
elaborate apologetics about how god is
using Donald Trump as his instrument to
make the country better.
Even if he himself is a flawed vessel.
Sometimes god works through flAwed
vessels.
Well,
if you position yourself as an ally,
even if you have previously send.
The beautiful thing about christianity
is all you have to do is say,
that's not me anymore.
I found jesus and I saw a pastor on
television going on about that and about
even when you're talking about trump,
you're talking about the trump before he
found jesus and he's like,
I don't have a past,
and he was like,
I am born again.
I do not have a past due you,
and he was going on about this whole
thing about this concept of trump is now
an agent of god,
but I don't necessarily even think it's
christianity.
I think that religion can be infinitely
malleable to the purposes of the moment.
He wouldn't have said that about obama
or whoever.
Right.
You know,
you pick and choose when you apply your
criteria.
Like I,
I did this once as an exercise for
myself.
There's certain phrases in the bible or
certain passages in the bible which are
sort of unapologetically left wing and
socialist,
right?
Just like there are others that are
unapologetically right wing and
authoritarian.
It's a big book full of different
things.
So I wondered like how.
What did they tell themselves?
What do the people who don't fall in
that side of the spectrum tell
themselves about these passages in the
bible?
So there's one famous,
very famous passage about how it is
easier for
a camel to pass through the eye of a
needle than for a rich man to enter the
kingdom of heaven.
Right?
Clearly,
I think that anyone who reads this says
this is an anti rich person statement so
you can google it.
Like so what do people say about this?
So my favorite explanation was that
sure,
it's impossible for camels to pass
through the eyes of a needle,
except if jesus helps them or if you
grind the camel down to dust and they
interpreted this as jesus said,
that only through jesus we get into
heaven.
That's really the only lesson they get.
Oh,
okay.
So that's nothing to do with rick.
all you have to do is find jesus.
And if you're rich,
you're good.
Well,
this is my time.
This is why I can't.
Even though I'm an atheist,
I'm,
I'm very happy to explain why I don't
think that god exists,
but I don't blame religion most of the
time for people's bad actions because I
think that religion is just sort of a
catalyst lets people find excuses for
their bad actions,
but it's usually the bad actions,
the desire to do bad actions that comes
first.
Do you ever look at religion as a
potential almost evolutionary software
program that's allowed people to sort of
adopt morality and impose certain
standards of behavior that are conducive
to.
So people talk about that.
And again,
I'm not an expert there.
I a little skeptical because it sounds
like too much of a story to tell after
the fact.
Right?
I think that we are a little bit quick
to attribute ideas and cultural concepts
to evolution.
Um,
but certainly,
you know,
religion was not like just science done
badly back in the day,
right?
Like what religion was,
was something much more expansive inter,
inter leafed with your life overall.
So it was not just how the world was
created and whether god exists.
It was how to be a good person,
how to live in your community,
things like that.
And you know,
disentangling these things is one of the
reasons why religion is still hanging
around,
right?
Like even after the kind of
underpinnings of the religion in terms
of understanding how the world works had
been removed by science.
The other functions are still there and
I,
I'm a big critic of my fellow
naturalists who have not put enough
effort into replacing the other
functions of religion.
Now that the,
uh,
the,
the claims about the world are no longer
viable.
That's a great way to present it.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's really a problem when there's so
many versions.
Yeah.
So,
I mean,
one of the many,
many reasons why I think that it's not
really credible to be religious
intellectually is because if in the
classic traditional western religious
sense where there's a god and he cares
about us,
right?
So there's all sorts of questions about
where we define the boundary of
religion,
whether buddhism is a religion or
something like that.
But in the usual sense that we,
that we grew up with in this country,
I'm surely if that were true,
god would have done a much better job of
explaining himself to us.
Right?
Like why would god give us his message
through a bunch of people in a tiny
country who didn't write?
You know,
like the new testament wasn't written
down until decades after the event.
None of the people who wrote it down
were eye witnesses.
Why is it only shared there?
I mean,
god,
it's god is god.
Right?
Like he could easily have showed up.
Everybody in the world talk to them and
explain how things were going and let
them make their own choices.
That would have been a much more
efficient way of getting the message
out.
And so it's just not really sensible to
think that.
So if god didn't exist,
then what you would imagine is that in
different countries,
in different parts of the world,
in different periods in history,
people would tell their own stories and
they'd all be a little bit different and
they'd be adaptive there,
local circumstances,
and they'd be utterly incompatible with
each other.
And that's exactly what you find.
Do you speculate as to what the origins
of the concept of god are since so many
different groups of people all over the
world have a very similar idea,
at least that there's some omnipotent
superpower that's controlling the
destiny of everything?
Yeah.
So number one,
I think that the idea of omnipotence was
actually somewhat late coming onto the
scene,
right?
Like if you dig into,
uh,
what was happening before 2000 years
ago,
um,
you know,
the hebrew god was not omnipotent at the
beginning,
right?
I mean,
the hebrews came out of a polytheistic
society where there were lots of
different gods around and you can trace
how their god evolved over time and
first,
you know,
became their god,
right?
Like there was one god that the,
that the hebrews were,
uh,
you know,
a worshiping and the egyptians and the
babylonians and worship other gods.
Then they started saying,
well,
our god is better than all the other
ones.
And then they started saying,
well,
the other ones don't even exist.
Right?
And it was an evolution over time and
omnipotence came late,
like you would talk about the gods
quarreling if you were a polytheistic
pagan culture.
It's actually makes more like a lot of
the world makes more sense if you
believe there's a whole bunch of gods
out there who disagree with each other,
right?
Suddenly lots of aspects of realities
come into focus.
But the idea,
there's supernatural,
very powerful influences in the.
I mean,
that's just an obvious idea.
I think like we're human beings,
we tend to,
as our first guest and understanding the
world,
treat the world as,
you know,
humanists,
like we're,
we're,
we're anthropomorphic,
right?
Like,
if something exists,
it must have been designed.
There must be a reason,
there must be a purpose.
Uh,
things work in a certain way because
someone made them that way and that we
don't see that person hanging around,
so it must be,
you know,
up there in the sky or something.
I don't think it's that hard to imagine
that all sorts of different cultures
would evolve.
Do you think it's also a function of us
growing up with mentors and father
figures and leaders and chieftains and
there's always someone who is the big,
the big kahuna.
So this is the sky daddy.
Yeah.
Sky daddy overlooks the big picture.
I think there's that.
And also the idea of your ancestors and
ancestor worship or veneration.
Right.
Which is also very almost universal,
you know,
in,
in primitive cultures,
I'm like,
you don't want to admit you died.
Right.
That's a sad thing to sit through.
So I don't know.
I'm sure they're real experts who know a
lot about the actual origins of these
things,
but,
but my point is just that I don't take
the commonalities between different sets
of religious beliefs as evidence for
anything other than there's a very human
thing to invent.
People search for meaning and they take
meaning from what or whatever religion
or ideology that they subscribe to and
they use it as a sort of a reason why
they're living.
It gives them hope.
It gives them,
gives them something.
Yeah.
It's a very common theme among religious
thinkers that if it weren't for the
existence of god or whatever,
there'd be no reason to live.
There'd be no reason to be a good person
and so forth.
And you know,
I think it's a,
it goes back to the motivation we have
as having bodies versus being in a
computer.
Like there's plenty of reasons to do
different things.
Like in,
in the big picture.
My last book,
I talk a lot about,
um,
you know,
we,
it's okay to admit that we as human
beings have desires that we,
there are things we care about,
that we want to be true.
And you can talk about why that's true
from evolution,
from biology and whatever,
but it doesn't matter why in some sense
we have goals.
We are not completely aimless.
Like we want to survive.
We want to flourish.
We want to be friends with people,
we want to have families or whatever it
is we want to do all that we put
together in terms of morality and ethics
and meaning and purpose comes out of
thinking hard and carefully,
hopefully about,
uh,
how to systematize and grow those
existing desires that we have into a way
of living in the world.
We don't need anything external to make
that happen.
We just need to sort of think about
where we are already and try to make it
better.
But you as an intelligent person who's
also an atheist who thinks very deeply
about things,
what do you cling to as a purpose for
life?
Do you have one to have like,
uh,
when you sit and think like,
what's the point of all this?
Do you,
do you.
I don't have a single one.
I don't have a monolithic purpose.
I have plenty of intermediate sized
purposes,
right?
Um,
otherwise,
you know,
why continue living?
I think that,
uh,
there's plenty of things I want to do to
achieve,
to experience,
to share,
to give to the world,
right?
That's big
feature,
right?
They give to the world that you're your
inner ear,
the way you interact with other human
beings and your effect on other human
beings gives you a,
gives you purpose.
Yeah.
And even if I think that when I die,
I will no longer exist in my feelings,
won't matter.
I have feelings right now about what the
world would be like even after I'm not
here anymore.
Right.
So I can still be motivated to make the
world a better place in ways that will
outlive me.
Even if I think that when I die,
it's really the end for me.
Hm.
And do you get down sometimes?
Do you ever do,
do you get like these periods of like,
you're like,
what is the purpose of all this?
Especially if you see some ridiculous
thing in the news or some horrific
tragedy.
And I'm
pretty,
I mean,
so for horrific tragedies.
No,
I'm,
I'm just,
you know,
fortunate enough to be a pretty even
keeled when it comes to that stuff I
don't have,
I don't struggle with depression or
despair or existential anxiety or
anything like that.
Uh,
when I was a kid,
when I was first starting thinking about
the universe and science and things like
that,
I would start wondering about,
well,
what if the universe hadn't existed at
all?
What if I weren't,
wasn't here,
uh,
and that may be loose sleep that night.
And I think like many people there,
there was a very definite moment when I
realized that I and everyone I knew
would die,
right?
and that,
so I woke up crying and my mom had to,
you know,
a comfort me because like,
I was like,
you know,
grand mom's gonna die and you're going
to die and I'm going to die.
And you know,
yeah.
But,
you know,
as a grownup,
no,
I think that,
uh,
you know,
I'm more or less.
So once again,
one of the future podcast guests that,
uh,
I'll be a next week's podcast will be by
a woman who was part of the death
positive movement.
Have you heard about this?
Yeah,
this is real stuff.
What,
who,
so don't distinguish,
don't,
don't confuse it.
There is a whole movement,
like an anti natal this movie or
something like that.
Forget what they call themselves,
but there's a whole movement that wants
human beings not to exist.
That's crazy,
but there are people who like that the
death positive movement is the
following,
like we're going to die.
We should face up to it,
we should accept it and we should deal
with it in a personally and culturally
positive way.
So for example,
like right now,
especially in the United States,
even compared to europe or other
countries,
we're terrible at dealing with death.
We put people in hospitals,
we take them away from their families,
away from their homes.
We refuse to admit that they're going to
die.
So we treat it as if the whole purpose
of the game is to squeeze out as many
more hours of life as possible,
no matter what,
the quality of that life is,
um,
and all that is just rubbish.
And we should be much more grown up
about it.
We should plan ahead.
You know,
when,
uh,
obama suggested that in the healthcare
system,
there should be some planning for what
happens when you die.
Sarah pailin came along with death
panels and that was a very effective
rhetorical strategy.
We don't want to think about the fact
that we're going to die.
We don't want to plan for it.
If we did plan for it,
it could be better.
We could die at home,
we could die with less pain,
we might not live as long as we don't
like do every single medical
intervention possible just to squeeze
out a few more breaths.
But it could be a much more life
affirming experience to die because the
people around us who,
who are there,
uh,
come across with an acceptance of what's
going on rather than the feeling that we
should just do everything we can to
prevent.
I had a similar situation happened
recently with a dog of mine who was a
massive,
reached 13 years old and from massive.
So it's very old and we had to put him
down because he couldn't walk anymore.
And uh,
he was,
it was brutally painful to watch him try
to get up and fall down and,
you know,
um,
but one of the things I was thinking was
that if this is my grandfather and not
my dog,
I would have to watch him suffer until
the bitter end.
Yeah.
I knew this dog wasn't going to go
backwards in time and become a puppy
again.
Right.
And knew his days were numbered.
He couldn't do anything.
Most days he just slept all day until it
was time to eat.
But it was getting to the point where I
had to carry him to his food.
Yeah.
And I knew that
there's no quality of life,
right?
No quality of life.
ANd it's,
in some sense it's even harder with the
dog because you can't talk them.
Right.
You can't explain to them what's going
on.
They can't explain to you what their
wishes are.
So you have to be the responsible one.
But yeah.
So everything legally and culturally in
the United States is we're not allowed
to relieve that pain or that,
that despair that you have in the end of
your life.
Some states,
including California,
are passing death with dignity laws
where basically it's what used to be
called assisted suicide,
but we don't call it that anymore.
I'm a you.
A doctor is allowed to give you the
means to end your own life when you're.
When you're near,
you have to be near a point of no
return,
but still clearly thinking enough to be
able to make that decision
for yourself and there's also an issue
with our real concern is their fear and
their this,
this experience being this terrifying
sort of step into the great beyond and
there's a tool to mitigate that and the
tool that has been shown to mitigate
that as psychedelics.
One of the big ones being psilocybin.
Psilocybin has a remarkable effect on
people that are going through stage four
cancer and a johns hopkins is studied
it.
There's,
there's,
there's quite a few studies that have
shown that people,
when you give them psilocybin,
they they're much more relaxed and much
more comfortable with this idea of
ending this life of this life.
You know,
it's gone through its course and get
this.
It's an inevitable thing and it's really
our biological limitations that are
terrified and sparking up all of these
intense primal fears of the end.
YeAh.
I'm actually a 100 percent in agreement
there.
My wife jennifer will lead to is a
science writer,
wrote a book called me and myself and
why searching for the science of self
and uh,
one of our friends said,
oh,
if you're gonna write a book about the
self,
you got to do lsd.
And so we did and she researched it.
And uh,
it's a fascinating history,
right?
And,
uh,
eldest huxley,
I don't know if you know about how this
whole story and he took lsd to do
exactly this.
He had throat cancer and it completely
helped you.
It's never fun to die,
right?
But it absolutely helped ease that
journey in a very simple way,
but just as we are a sort of immature
society that doesn't want to face up to
the reality of our eventual deaths were
also very culturally conservative and
squeamish about drugs.
Right.
And so were.
We don't even let people do research on
some of these drugs.
and so I think that,
yeah,
we have a lot of growing up to do when
it comes to,
uh,
not just living a good life,
but also having a good death and also so
paying attention to actual scientists
who have studied these compounds and
really understand what the effects of
them are and have researched them deeply
and have personal experiences with them
and they're saying these,
the,
these things have been demonized and
there are tools that we can use
to sort of mitigate a lot of the real
issues that we have,
whether it's culturally or personally
with these transitionary times,
like death is inevitable.
So now that we know it's inevitable,
you tell me what the main problem would
be with someone taking psilocybin before
they die and letting them ease their way
through this.
But you know,
it's the same reaction that doesn't want
people to have a basic income,
right?
There is a sort of moral feeling that
you're weak.
You don't struggle against dad
everything.
And it's silly,
right?
It's no sense,
but it's very,
very common.
It's so weird that,
that,
that the universal basic income topic is
one of those knee jerk reaction or
topics that I,
myself,
my friend eddie wong,
have introduced it to me for the first
time and I,
my initial knee jerk reaction was,
ah,
you can't do that to people.
Human nature,
people are going to get lazy.
And then the more I thought about it,
I was like,
well,
if you just cover their food and their
rent,
are they really going to get,
is it really going to kill their
ambition?
Like why would that kill it?
Is our own ambition,
our ambition uniquely tied to just
survival.
That doesn't make sense.
Well,
and it's a weird.
It's the same weird thing that people
use against,
you know,
having a progressive tax system.
Like if we have,
we tax people's money,
they won't want to work anymore,
but you know,
if you know,
you still want more money,
we don't them so much that you have less
money to work.
That's not how it works.
And I think like what,
so but,
but also for the,
for the universal basic income stuff,
I think people have to reconcile
themselves.
So what if someone wants to just sit
around and play video games all day,
brian,
is that the worst thing in the world?
Like,
I mean,
I think that there will be people like
that.
There will still be other people who
want to write poetry and build sailboats
and you know,
build a spacecraft,
et cetera,
or build artificial intelligence.
And you wouldn't.
What if everyone could do whatever they
want when they were kids when they're 10
years old,
they were,
they were taught a good programming
language and could,
you know,
make up whatever apps and programs they
wanted.
Like there'll be a whole different world
than what we live in right now.
And it might be very exciting.
Well,
creatively it could possibly expand a
lot of people's potentials,
right?
Where they no longer have to have a job.
So they could do whatever this one thing
is that they're thinking about doing.
Write a book or a screenplay,
develop something in the short term.
I don't know if a basic income work sort
of economically,
but I think that if we believe that
there's more and more stuff that can be
done by computers,
by robots or whatever automation,
then it's absolutely something that
should be taken seriously.
Yeah.
So I think that this is the whole thing,
and this is great because we've been
talking a lot of different angles about
the fact that the shape of the world is
changing in a way that makes what it
means to be human changing and,
uh,
facing up to what those changes are,
the fact that we died,
in fact,
we make up purpose and meaning for
ourselves and in our lives and the fact
that what we are physically in terms
of bodies and,
and machines and so forth is Also
changing.
So in this part of the theme of my
podcast,
I hope is that,
uh,
to think through some of these issues to
sort of.
I don't know the answers,
but I want to ask the questions about,
you know,
who we are,
what we're living,
what should we be doing about it?
Because god's not going to give us the
answer.
Well,
I think
podcasts like yours and I mean any
podcasts where people are really
carefully considering issues there,
I think what's important about them that
really didn't exist before is that
someone can sort of digest these very
complex subjects through to people
having a conversation about it that
perhaps are more informed and have more
data and have more experience and have
more thought about these particular
issues.
So what you can do and what sam harris
can do in a lot of people can do that
are creating these podcasts about these
really complex issues,
is you start that conversation and this
seed gets planted into someone's head
and maybe they carry with them at work.
They carry with them,
carry it with them when they're on the
subway or during the commute home,
and then they become a part of the
broader conversation that we have as a
couple.
Exactly.
Yeah,
and that'S why I sort of want to not
draw a distinction between science and
other ways of thinking deeply about the
world.
Because I want people to.
You know,
I.
I've often said this as a joke,
I want to live in a world where people
work hard in the factory and they go out
for a drink afterwards and talk about
their favorite interpretation of quantum
mechanics.
Right.
I want that to be the kind of thing
people are bullshitting about,
you know,
over beer.
That'd be a world I want to live in is
that.
Have you ever run into a quantum
mechanics conversation at a bar?
There are far too many people who think
they understand something about quantum
mechanics and are going to explain it to
me.
So I'm at the existing conversations to
be a little bit more informed.
Yeah.
Well it's.
There's a few people online.
Someone has.
You got to get this guy on and then I've
listened to them talk and I'm like,
I'm pretty sure
that that guy's full of shit,
but I can't really point out how I know
that a lot of crack,
but feel free to email me.
I will help you out if a.
Well,
I don't want to bring this one guy up
on,
but I'll talk to you about it the year.
Yeah,
there's a lot of woo out there,
but also it's quantum mechanics,
a lot of very respectable people who
sound crazy if you don't know too deeply
what they're,
what they're saying.
So that is the fineman quote,
right?
If you think,
you know quantum mechanics,
you definitely don't know quantum
mechanics exactly.
Which is the whole point of my book is
to overcome that feeling because I think
what happened is,
you know,
it's true that we don't agree.
We physicists don't agree in what
quantum mechanics says,
but we now fetishize the fact that we
don't understand it.
Like it's good that we don't understand
it.
Like if you try to understand it too
hard,
you're wasting your time.
And I,
I so disagree with that view.
So I think the quantum mechanics is and
should be understandable by everybody.
What a squirrely concept.
It's,
it's.
Yeah.
It's weird and that's why I'm a lot of
people.
There's a lot of people who I know who
friends of mine who are professors in
philosophy departments because they got
a phd in physics and they realized what
they really wanted to do was to think
about quantum mechanics in a deep way
and they would never get a job in a
physics department doing that to put
philosophy would let them do it.
Oh wow.
Yeah.
Interesting.
And what they're really doing is
physics,
but they're doing it in a way that
philosophers are happy with and
physicists.
And what year did the concept of quantum
mechanics become invented?
Invented in test.
And it started in 1900.
Exactly,
but they sort of perfected the modern
version around 19,
27.
What was the original thought process,
do you know?
Yeah,
it's a.
It was the.
The history is amazing and a messy
because they didn't have so much
weirdness going on.
It was max plunk plunk radiation if you
ever heard of that.
No,
I'm a german physicist.
So black body radiation,
something glows when you heat it up.
Right?
So basically what happens when you heat
something up is all the atoms and
molecules start vibrating.
There's a lot of charged particles.
A charged particle has an electric field
around it,
and if you vibrate it,
the electric field starts vibrating.
We call that light or radiation,
right?
Gravity.
Electromagnetic waves are being
admitted.
So you could in the year 1900,
you could sit down and do a calculation.
What should that look like?
You know,
if you heed everything up,
how much radiation should it give off?
And there the problem was it should give
off an infant amount of radiation at
very long wavelength,
which is obviously false,
right?
Because obviously not how things really
work.
So there was this blatant disagreement
between everything we thought we knew.
And then in the late 19th century,
in the 18 hundreds,
people really thought in physics that
they were close to the answer,
right?
They had a picture where there were
particles like electrons and protons.
And then there were fields like the
electromagnetic field and the
gravitational field.
And the particles were matter and the
fields push them together.
They interacted,
they,
you know,
they were the forces,
right.
And this picture was so good and so
compelling that people were basically
like,
we're almost done with physics,
right?
We almost have it all figured out.
And then there were a couple of little
things like the black body radiation
that you made a prediction.
It was wildly off.
And so they're like,
well,
what's going to happen?
So plonk says,
well maybe when this electromagnetic
radiation is admitted,
it's not just a continual stream of
radiation.
Maybe if like individual little packets
of energy,
he had no reason to say that.
Like it's just out of the blue is just
pulled out of his butt.
Right.
So he was just sitting there with a pad.
Yeah,
just contemplate and think what if.
And he goes,
what if he gets exactly the right
answer?
Right?
The data.
Right.
And he said,
there it is.
And he's like,
he public and he,
he himself wasn't sure what to make of
this.
He's like,
I got this idea.
It gives the right answer.
Who knows?
That is crazy.
And it was five years later,
young man named albert einstein said,
well,
I know what's going on.
Those little packets of energy or
themselves,
particles,
that light is not a wave.
There's particles that are being given
off photons,
would they relate,
are called right?
And that's what he won the nobel prize
for it.
I just,
I never won a nobel prize for
relativity.
He won the nobel prize for inventing
photons basically.
And then,
uh,
so there was that.
So that was,
there were two tracks going on.
Remember I just said in the 19th
century,
it was the world's made of particles and
fields.
So the first thing that happened is
people started thinking about these
fields,
electromagnetic field.
And einstein saYs,
well,
there's something a little bit particle
like about it,
right?
Is not a hardened from distinction.
Then separately,
they looked at adam's right?
So you have a electron orbiting and adam
orbiting the nucleus of an atom.
You have this picture that everyone has
seen the cartoon of an atom,
right?
with the electron orbiting around.
Again,
you can make a prediction.
That electron moving around the nucleus
of anatomies should be giving off light.
It's a moving electron when you,
when you accelerate and electronic gives
off light,
so it should lose energy and spiral into
the middle.
It should not just stay in the same
orbit.
It should be losing energy by radiating
energy away.
You can.
You can calculate for a typical adam,
how long should it take before the adam
shrinks to zero size and the answer is
like a hundred billion to of a second.
So all the atoms that you and I are made
of should just go right away.
Rapper that break,
give off light and squint.
Scrunch down to zero size.
That's a problem,
right?
That's,
that's not compatible with the data.
So niels bohr in 1913 ish comes along
and says,
I have an idea.
What if the electrons don't do that?
Because they can't.
What if there's certain orbits that
they're allowed to have and they're not
allowed to have any other ones?
Again,
just pulled out of nowhere for no good
reason,
but he says,
if that's true,
I predict the following,
you know,
spectrum of radiation from hydrogen.
You know,
look it up,
it's exactly right,
fits the data,
perfect jesus and people like what the
hell is going on?
and then it was.
So that took like another 10,
15 years before people like heisenberg
and schrodinger built that up into
saying it's not just that waves of light
have a certain particle illness.
It's also that particles like electrons
have a certain waviness and there's a
wave function and they're getting in
quantum mechanics and we're still
arguing about it to this day.
Well,
it's such a difficult concept to wrap
your head around that.
It's been distorted,
right?
It's like,
especially in the womb merchants.
I have a,
a fun part of my book.
I list like 20 titles that came up in
amazon.
When you type the word quantum in
quantum love,
quantum power,
quantum yoga,
quantum healing,
quantum politics,
quantum theology,
you know,
it's used for every crazy bit of
nonsense that you've ever heard of.
How do you mitigate that?
Write more books,
have more podcasts,
keep talking,
right?
Like you know,
you'll never get rid of it entirely
there.
As you may have heard,
there are people who still believe the
earth is flat.
Oh,
I haven't heard,
so you're never going to completely get
rid of the wrong ideas,
but you can get the right ideas out
there more effectively.
Yeah.
Do you think that it's possible that.
I mean this concept was created and
invented somewhere around the 19
hundreds.
Is it possible that another theory
that's just as revolutionary is being
developed right now and through things
like the large hadron collider and
search for understanding the elementary
particles of the universe,
is it possible that we could develop a
new theory and are there any that are
being contemplated right now,
so it's absolutely possible that what
einstein and tried his best to do right?
He thought that he could do better than
quantum mechanics and he did not
succeed.
The big difference is that when real
quantum mechanics was developed between
1,990,
27 at every step,
it was because there was some dramatic
disagreement between the theory and the
data and right now our theories are good
enough that they fit the data really,
really well.
So we're trying to make,
I'm,
I and others are proposIng new ideas to
try to understand,
you know,
how spacetime emerges in quantum
mechanics and things like that and you
can try to do better than quantum
mechanics,
but it's all just on pure principle,
right on pure,
like coherence and beauty and elegance
because we have a theory that fits the
data fine.
And it's so much harder to make progress
when you're trying to do it in your
brain rather than doing it by data.
Hmm.
So as for right now,
there's nothing else being contemplated
that.
No,
that's pretty unique.
Is being contemplated.
Nothing promising.
Nothing.
Nothing,
nothing emergent.
Like there are people who think they can
do better.
There is no one who agrees that someone
else is doing better right now.
Right.
Are there any standout theories that
people have sort of,
I think replacing quantum mechanics or
even improving quantum mechanics is
because there's no guidance whatsoever
from experiments.
Um,
there's not even a sort of leading
thing.
In fact,
I don't think it's the right way to go.
I think that given right now,
given the fact that we have quantum
mechanics and yet don't quite understand
it,
our job should be to understand what we
got,
what,
what has come out of the large hadron
collider.
I know that they,
there was some discussion as to whether
or not they found the higgs boson or
boston.
I say bows on,
but pose on was with a z.
It's pronounced with [inaudible],
but it's spelled with a dance boo son.
Oh,
it is.
It's pronounced [inaudible].
I only read it.
I never had a physicist a bose on,
on.
Yep.
Okay.
So the higgs boson there,
there was some discussion that they had
absolutely proven its existence,
but then there was also some debate
about that.
So it's actually a very bittersweet.
The large hadron
collider.
Bittersweet.
Well,
yeah.
Life doesn't promise you a rose garden.
Uh,
we found the higgs boson fairly quickly
after getting the large hadron collider
up to speed.
We founded in 2012.
You can read that in my other book,
the particle at the end of the universe.
Um,
but we didn't find anything else.
So did we find the higgs boson?
Yes,
it is crystal clear that we found a
particle and that particle is exactly
what we predicted 40 years before that
the higgs boson would look like it talks
to the other particles in the same way
it has the right mass and has the same
lifetime and all those things.
But there is a puzzle.
So this is what we have.
We don't have blatant disagreement
between theory and experiment.
Well,
we have our puzzles,
right?
Well,
we have our mismatches between our
informal expectation and what reality is
doing.
So in one way,
uh,
so there's a number which is the mass of
the higgs bozon.
We measured it.
Okay.
One hundred and 30 some times the mass
of a proton.
But there's a guess as to what the mass
should have been if,
if nature.
We're natural nature is natural,
but if our notion of nature have worked
out the way it was,
what should the mass of the higgs bows
on?
B.
And it's literally a quadrillion times
bigger than what it actually does.
What's a quadrillion tended to 15.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
That's what I'm not making this up.
You can google this.
Uh,
the mass of the higgs boson should be
enormously bigger by sort of what our
intuitive feelings about quantum
mechanics and quantum field theory say.
So there's a known problem,
has been known for a long time called
the hierarchy problem.
And so even before we discovered the
higgs,
we knew it wasn't that heavy.
We knew as much,
much lighter than what it should be.
So the hierarchy problem was a known
thing and people said,
how could it be true?
Well,
you have to change the theory a little
bit.
You have to like add some new particles
or predict some new features,
a physics going on.
And many,
many people,
myself included,
we're very optimistic that the large
hadron collider would find evidence for
what was going on,
would find more particles than just the
higgs bozon.
It's found nothing else maybe would find
supersymmetry or extra dimensions or
strings or some new kinds of
combinations of old particles.
It's found nothing else.
So now we have a puzzle and no answers.
Right.
And that's,
that's the most frustrating thing
because they're the.
I mean,
people don't want to say this out loud,
but here we go.
Since no one's listening to this,
right,
um,
the last time particle physicists were
surprised by an experimental result from
a particle accelerator was in the 19
seventies.
Since then we found new particles,
but they were already predicted and
expected to be there.
We've never found a particle since the
seventies that no one had anticipated
finding long before.
Well,
just the idea of a particle collider as
a lay person,
as a person just looking on the outside,
like you got to create crashes.
Yet like that's the only way to find out
what's going on with the,
the basic building blocks of the
universe.
You have to rush things and knew each
other.
I know.
Yeah.
Well,
so the secret to that is that really the
world is not made of particles.
It's really made a fields,
right?
That's quantum field theories.
The laBel given to this.
So for the electromagnetic field,
for the light coming out of the light
bulbs,
that makes sense.
We figured out the fields first and I'll
leave down the particles later.
But it's also true,
as we were just talking about,
for the particles like electrons,
protons,
quirks,
neutrinos.
These are all vibrations and fields.
So what do you should think about when
you think of colliding particles?
It's not little pea shaped things that
are bumping into each other and
smushing,
right?
It's really like a little vibration into
fields that are coming into the same
place and overlapping and all the
particles that could potentially exist
are fields that are out there in the
world and usually they're just quietly
sitting there not doing anything.
But when these particles that you made
in the large hadron collider hitting
each other,
that sets up vibrations in every field
in the universe,
like very faint little jiggles up and
down,
and then you look and you see in quantum
mechanics says there's a probability
will look one way versus another.
So the way you make it how in the world
you make a higgs boson by colliding
protons,
even though the higgs boson is over a
hundred times heavier than a proton,
right?
The answer is really.
You're setting up vibrations and the
higgs field,
which was always there all along,
and then you very quickly actually you
can't.
The higgs,
the higgs boson disappears so quickly.
You'll never see it.
You see what it decays into,
you see what it converts into.
The vibrations and the higgs field get
transferred to vibrations and other
things and that's what we observe in our
detector.
So if you,
if you are able to do this sort of
conceptual switched from particles to
fields than the reason why we need an
accelerator and a collider to make new
particles begins to make a bit more
sense,
doesn't it?
Don't you?
Oh,
I get it now.
There was something that I had read.
I'm trying one more thing.
like if you're in a room with two pianos
and you play one piano,
the piano will start vibrating along
with it a little bit.
Ah,
that's an interesting way to look at it.
That's the one field,
the quarks and gluons and the proton
start the higgs field vibrating a little
bit and that's what we eventually see.
I'm glad you mentioned glue on's.
Um,
that's one of the things that I had read
about that they did,
they had either discovered or were able
to observe with the large hadron
collider was a believer.
It's called quark glue on plasma.
Right.
You got it right.
Thank you.
Um,
which is an immensely dense thing that
the,
the way they described it was something
like something that was a fraction of
the size of a sugar cube would weigh as
much as the earth itself.
Yeah,
that's right.
So usually what you try to do with
particle accelerators is discovered new
particles.
Right?
So to do that,
why haven't you discovered them already?
Usually it's because they're too heavy.
It takes energy to make them equals mc
squared.
If their mass is big and a lot of energy
in as smallest possible region.
That's how you make new particles.
So to do that,
you take some particles that are pretty
small,
like protons and you smash them
together.
And that's how we discovered the higgs
and we're looking for other things.
But maybe your goal in life is not to
discover new particles,
but to understand the particles that we
already know about,
right?
In that case,
maybe you want to see what happens when
you get,
like you say,
a huge number of particles together in
the same place with a lot of energy and
see how they interact with each other
and make a plasma.
Plasma is like what's at the center of
the sun,
right?
But instead of electrons and photons,
we're going to make it a quarks and
gluons.
So instead of smashing together protons
approach on has three corks each,
right?
we smashed together the nucleus of a
heavy adam like an iron or lead adam,
right?
Which has,
you know,
dozens of,
of protons and neutrons in it.
So we get as many particles as we can
squeeze together in the same place.
So the energy is a bit more diffuse,
but we get to study how they interact
with each other because that's what
conditions were like near the big bang.
Lots of particles going on.
It wasn't just two particles smacking
into each other.
So we're learning a lot about what
conditions were like in the very,
very early universe.
What is the mass of this stuff?
This core gluon plasma,
like there's some insane number that uh,
I remember reading,
yes.
But by neural implant is failing me,
so it's not remember the number right
now,
but we could google it.
It's very dense,
gigantic,
massive.
If it's a bit of a cheat,
right?
Like,
you know,
so I always,
I get laughed when I give talks on the
higgs boson because uh,
I mentioned that the hate,
the lifetime of the higgs bozon already
said it disappears very quickly.
Right.
So I say it's one zeptosecond,
which is true.
That's just like,
you know,
you when I say quadrillion,
you're like,
what does that number?
And I said 10 and 15,
but who cares?
What's the point of a zeptosecond really
short.
So I say it's a zeptosecond,
which is a really short period of time
and everyone laughs it's 10 to the minus
21 seconds.
But who cares if I said 10 to the minus
28,
would that have changed your opinion at
the expose on,
in any way?
Like it's a really short period of time,
right?
Like five quadrillion.
Is that more than a trillion?
Yeah.
It doesn't really affect your life in
any meaningful way.
What is going on right now with,
with science that is particularly
compelling to you?
Other than things we've already
discussed?
You know,
I'm very interested in entropy and
complexity,
complex systems.
Um,
there's a wonderful place in New Mexico
in santa fe just called the santa fe
institute,
which is devoted to the study of complex
systems.
Physicists are really,
really good at studying simple systems,
a couple of articles at a time,
right?
And there's certain techniques they have
this,
this is why we have theories that
explain all the data because we're
asking questions about the simplest
possible things that we can.
Once you have a bacterium or a,
an elephant or an economic system or an
internet,
these are very,
very complex systems with many moving
parts,
interact with each other and complicated
ways.
And so you can start asking yourself
questions about are there laws that
govern the behavior of these complex
systems that we wouldn't have noticed if
we just studied them piece by piece?
And the answer is a little bit yes,
he to keep advertising my podcast.
But we had Jeffrey West on the podcast.
Who is hate it.
I,
yeah,
I shouldn't hate it.
That's the whole reason.
Like I'm not actually telling you the
truth,
but saw through me there.
I love advertising my podcast.
I had Jeffrey West who's a brilliant
physicist who actually started as a
particle physicist and then when we were
going to have,
you remember,
we were going to build the
superconducting super collider in the
United States.
This was going to be our version of the
lhc large hadron collider.
But the ssc would have been both sooner
and better.
It would have been higher energy
administration,
correct?
That's right.
And uh,
well it started during the reagan
administration and then clinton let it
be killed by congress.
Uh,
so Jeffrey West,
who was a particle physics at the time
said like,
it's my life's work.
I was hoping for this to come online and
I'm not going to see what,
what else can I do?
And he,
he found that in biology there are what
is known as scaling laws.
So if you look at different organisms
like mammals or whatever,
right,
you can plot different quantities like
their mass and their metabolism or their
lifespan and things like that.
And it turns out that they are related
to each other.
It's not,
you know,
if you know how heavy a mammal is,
you know how long it's going to live,
you can figure that out.
Um,
and in fact it's related to the
metabolism also.
So there's a wonderful.
So basically the bigger you are,
the longer you live.
also,
the bigger you are,
the slower your heartbeats and they
exactly cancel out so that every mammal
lives for about one and a half billion
heartbeats on.
I've read that and I relayed that to my
friends that are runners and I was like,
you gotta think if you're an ultra
marathon runner,
look,
my friend cameron hanes,
he runs these 240 mile runs this.
He just did that in death valleY and the
bad.
What I keep saying that ass,
but it's like the bed.
Water.
Yeah.
Thirty five mileS.
These are crazy.
So you gotta think like exertion over
long periods.
You tell them you're juicing up your
battery.
You don't get a finite number,
a fixed number of heartbeats to begin
with,
but you know what they do do though?
It lowers their resting heart rate,
which is fascinating.
That's right.
So all this extreme exercise,
oh,
you're wasting heartbeats,
but also your heartbeat is probably like
78.
Whereas there's this 34,
now they're winning overall it totally
compensates weird,
right?
It's a weird sort of intuitive thing.
It's
100 billion and a half is just an
average.
But the point is,
so Jeffrey West and his collaborator.
So why?
Why is it that you know,
you can't make an animal that's twice as
big and lives the same blank.
Yeah.
What?
What's,
what's going on?
So they actually came up with a theory
based on the fact that our bodies are
right,
our circulatory system or respiratory
system,
our nervous system,
and they all have the same structure
like trees,
right?
Like fractals and,
and they were able to show that if,
if our,
if the resources that our biology uses
travel through these fractal networks in
a three dimensional space,
right?
The weird three dimensional beings,
then you get these scaling laws,
you get the this universal behavior and
fits the data and now you know,
you can extend it to the behavior of
things like cities and corporations and
stuff like that.
So when you get people in a city,
they walk faster,
right?
Like people in little small towns mosey
down the street and everyone in the big
city walks faster.
And why is that?
Like,
what's going on?
And there's,
you,
you would not be surprised to learn that
there are more patents,
uh,
that are generated in a big city than
this small town.
But there are even more patents per
person in a big city.
Like living in that dense environment
changes the rate of innovation and
things like that.
So they're studying how we can try to
extract these,
not quite as precise as particle
physics,
but still very general robust
relationships between these large
systems and learn from that,
how to make things more sustainable,
more creative,
more innovative,
more livable and things like that.
So I think all this stuff is very fast.
They've actually done studies where
they've put cameras up on streets and
they watch people walk by and the amount
of footsteps they take per minute,
they can accurately depict or they can
accurately predict how many people live
in that city.
I believe that.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Just based on how and also how fast you
talk.
Yep.
How fast you talk.
Um,
uh,
how fast the line moves in the dmv
office in,
I think it's dublin.
I'm not exactly sure but,
but Jeffrey West has this picture of
dublin.
There's this tourist area.
And so it's both a big city where a lot
of people live,
but it's also a famous tourist
destination.
We're foreigners come in and wander
around.
Right.
And the locals who live in a big city
and want to get where they want to go
became so frustrated with all these
moseying tourists.
They literally made walking lanes for
the locals where you have to walk
faxed.
Right.
You're not allowed to meander.
Oh wow.
That is interesting.
That's interesting.
Listen,
thank you very much for doing this.
Thank you for being you.
Thank you for this podcast.
You're putting out the books you write.
It's so important for people like me to
have someone like you that can sort of
eliminate a lot of these things.
And,
uh,
I really,
really appreciate your time.
My pleasure.
Thanks for being a role model.
Help inspiring me here.
My pleasure and mindscape podcast.
That's right.
It's available now.
Everywhere,
everywhere for her.
Hopefully.
Yeah.
Dried.
Beautiful.
Thank you.
Sean carroll.
Ladies and gentlemen.